the church of what's happening now is
presented by on it
this show is brought to you by indochina
go to indochino.com or visit a showroom
and you're going to get premium suits
for a fraction of the cost right now our
listeners can get any premium indochino
suit for just 389
at indochino.com and promo code church
at checkout and don't forget shipping is
free
indochino.com promo code church
and the show is brought to you by
hellotushy.com but days are back guys
the church of what's happening now is
proud to introduce you to hellotushy.com
hellotushy.com makes portable devices
that spray your butt clean with water go
to hellotushy.com church right now to
get ten percent off of your order that's
hellotushy.com
church
kick that mu lee
martin luther [ __ ] king day
baby
we could have showed up with some soul
music
but this is the [ __ ] soul we're
talking about here
the church of what's happening now
[ __ ]
monday
the 15th of the month it's halfway there
and you're still digging around kick
that mule lee
i want them to feel the [ __ ] passion
of the black [ __ ] crows
i want to thank my main man
john petrovic
here you go baby baby why can't you sit
still
lee syett
kate quigley
and your uncle joey diaz [ __ ]
here we go we kick it
[Music]
are you [ __ ] kidding me break out
that syringe [ __ ]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
kate quigley in house lisa at the flying
jew
heavy duty night here on the church of
what's happened now shroomages
refrigerators chocolates tequila we're
going deep
into the murky waters if you're a
christian hang up now well joy when you
were like going and like partying what
was your drink because mine was always
tequila that was mine i used to switch
[ __ ] uh southern comfort an orange
juice a [ __ ]
there was a for a while i went on that
whiskey
20 what's that other there's like an uh
an aperitif it's like a called 36 it's
got a number to it
that sounds expensive
i used to drink everything lee when
you're a coke fiend you drink whatever's
in the [ __ ] house paint syrup
cough syrup
paint that out whatever [ __ ] you got
i'll mix it with water i've never done
coke and drink paint thinner whatever
what the [ __ ] you got [ __ ] this
you're the one on his level that you
know that [ __ ] red drink
the red [ __ ] hawaiian punch yeah
whatever you drink whatever you got i'll
drink
with rum you just right you just became
creative when you're [ __ ] fiend it's
five in the morning you just become
creative you got tequila and milk go you
got you got [ __ ] chocolate syrup put
it in there too
i think that is how the mudslide was
invented so let me ask you something so
what you're telling me is that all the
asian girls get the hot guys yeah i just
said every every guy i think has an
asian girl fantasy at some point every
girl i know who's asian has a super hot
boyfriend
really yeah yeah
in fact
i'm
i mean my ex-boyfriend was asian and
super hot he was like 6'3 and he wasn't
super into asian girls and i think i
kind of developed a fetish for asian men
because uh
i don't have to compete with asian women
they're the only guys that seem to not
be as super into them that's crazy i am
so [ __ ] up though
i'm literally saying this i'm like oh
i'm really [ __ ] up this makes no sense
abort abort when i was like [ __ ] 28 i
got into comedy
i was i was thinking to myself it would
be nice to date like an asian girl they
could yeah they started getting really
hot like you know
when i came from cuba they were still
like [ __ ] to themselves they wouldn't
say none they'd bow
nobody would say nothing and then but my
first girlfriend on paper was really
chinese
when i was like six i had this little
chinese girl in the first grade that i
would go to a house and play with her
and i'd go to a house and eat and they'd
give me like candy with the paper on it
and [ __ ] i'm not kidding you lived on
88th street and her father was a
designer for schultz
so we would always go see the early
screenings of like uh
charlie brown and all those
[ __ ] so we were like friends
altered when i was six and seven
like her and i would hold hands and [ __ ]
like that but then i forgot about the
whole thing and i'm done with my life
and then they started getting cute i
don't know what happened you know you
started seeing asians and they were
mingling in white clubs and [ __ ]
not that i had you know was going to
clubs but then i started dating this
crazy girl and she had a korean
girlfriend
and we all became friends and she had a
boyfriend and we all became friends the
chick was [ __ ] banging and one day my
girlfriend came to me and said i'm
moving to new york to go work in uh
publicity
and guess what the asians boyfriend he
had to move to washington state to
pursue his master's degree
so it was like [ __ ] bringing a mouse
to the cat
i just think they're i even i think
they're just so cute they're so the
girls yeah the girls are petite but they
have little waist and hip
faces they look young forever beautiful
yeah korean girls chinese japanese
they're [ __ ] i love their body they
love how like tiny they are yeah i used
to want to be one even like my
daughter's godmother is really a
knockout she really is she's filipino
she really is a knockout oh yeah they're
beautiful yeah she really is a knockout
i didn't know you dated asian men i i've
dated two asian guys good yeah yeah i'm
in the asian guys i like them okay no
you're a [ __ ] savage
i'm surprised i'll beat any guy i'll
date any kind of guy if he's cool and
cute he could be asian or what he can be
whatever i'm into middle eastern guys
too i just found out really yeah no [ __ ]
one minute you suck a middle eastern
dick the next minute you got a bomb on
you [ __ ] yelling at people
who the [ __ ] knows what they're gonna do
to you next thing i got your eyeballs
closed you can't sniff
you know who [ __ ] knows i don't know
nothing about not the [ __ ] do i know but
that's good that you're out there you're
doing comedy you were in [ __ ]
sacramento last week which is a great
club and i tell you it's a fun block
they love you all the i was out with all
the waitresses after the show my big
girl the big uh blonde oh wait corey the
bartender no she's a big big blonde she
got really big she went on depression
pills or something huh and mixed up with
cocktails and it was all over
she's really nice though i love the
girls okay they've been up there for
years yeah yeah they all love you great
club it's the best it was so much fun
and down the corner i got a red lobster
they got the [ __ ] thing across the
street they got the sushi place i know i
know because i talked to you and you
said oh they got a great sushi place
around the corner it stays up until one
i started asking around about it did you
go okay i didn't get there now where'd
you eat the four [ __ ] days you were
there uh i ate uh at the club
did you get at the hotel did you get the
free breakfast i got room service one
day yeah there's free breakfast i got
room service one day to watch football
with friends and it was sixty dollars
and it took two hours because they
ordered the room service from like a
hotel no no you can't yeah there's no
room service day that's that hotel is
simple you keep it simple they gotta
they got one elliptical yeah they've got
one kettlebell and they got one [ __ ]
thing it's in a hut they keep it simple
there there's no drugs literally in a
hut
there's no the gym is a high it's a high
i know i've been staying at that hotel
for 15 [ __ ] years and i love it i
love that hotel i love the whole block
why don't you switch hotels because
listen the rooms are amazing one of
those clubs you don't switch hotels
across the street was an asian barbecue
place that ari would live in there
ari would call me from that place oh
really they closed no they closed down
and then they had the gap they have that
clothing store across the street off the
rack like
nordstrom is off too yeah yeah so you've
got three days of entertainment yeah
yeah all you can eat frozen yogurt yeah
that's right there's a starbucks right
there one [ __ ] block there's in and
out one block
yeah and chili's you don't need a car no
you don't need a [ __ ] there's a chili's
there's a place called twin peaks which
is like a local hooters you want to
attract me to your comedy club i don't
need a [ __ ] car like cleveland
cleveland is 50 [ __ ] yards i'm so
with you the hotel to the club across
the street is that that [ __ ] mabel's
barbecue oh jesus
christ that's what you're saying jesus
[ __ ] christ then they took me to the
famous [ __ ] pastrami place in two
days i went to the best places in
cleveland i mean it was off the [ __ ]
chain well you know you don't really
need that many places because whenever i
go anywhere with you like the true
testament if joey diaz likes something
is if he goes eight times in two and a
half i went to slime i did that too i
went to slime yeah corned beef oh
they're famous for corned beef the first
time i went there like in 98
i went in the afternoon there was a line
around the [ __ ] block but the dude i
knew knew people
so we cut the [ __ ] line this time
there was really nobody there just some
army guys
and we went in there and got two eggs
with uh that was the day of my sleep
apnea [ __ ] machine broke oh my god
you didn't get any sleep the [ __ ]
first night was hard oh god let me tell
you something
the day was great i panicked
i really thought i was gonna get caught
in traffic i picked the 10 30 a.m flight
which is a horror show but it all
[ __ ] worked out okay it all worked
out i got up at six
and i left at
7 15 and i thought i would get there by
nine i needed to be there at 9 30. oh
10 30 flight it was a nine it was a 10
35 flight
so i had to be that 9 35
so the night before lee and i got [ __ ]
up and he set the phone for me
for uber
not the regular car and not the x the
black car but the one in the middle a
nicer car it's like premium or something
so okay this is only my luck you
understand me
so i didn't even know there was a third
level of uber no no it's it's between
uber and then
started it also lyft has it also now so
um i set it for 7 15 i'm ready to go
protein shake breakfast i see the baby
baby comes out before i leave i give her
a kiss my wife
i get in the car he's an armenian dude
lexus beautiful
[ __ ] cuts off half of [ __ ] burbank
boulevard gets on the 405. i'll tell you
something i was there in no time
guy turned out to be great i gave him a
star of death
yeah i was eating edibles in it and he's
like that's your tip oh yeah no i gave
him i gave him a 20 but i also gave him
a star i thought he was gonna say like i
gave him a five star rating no no you
ready i don't even know how to give
somebody a five star ready
so you ready for this yeah he goes you
want me to pick you up on sunday or yeah
only an armenian could figure this [ __ ]
out
he said i'll pick you up but [ __ ] uh
i'll do the uber for you in the car so
you don't have to tremendous
on the way he picked me up sunday and
he's telling me all about how he ate the
start he got [ __ ] up
he had to drink a gallon of milk oh my
god and he's on he's our new driver but
let me tell you the whole thing i get
into the airport i walk right through
i mean it's empty boom first class
ticket upgrade boom walk to the gate i'm
gate 85 i walk all the way to gate 89
i'm stoned to the gills
i just ate a rocket chocolate i hate
like three or four stars i must have
like right now
at 6 30 in the morning i'm in my
backyard doing bong hits of [ __ ] that
carrie fisher wheat the original og what
is it and that's late for him we've been
on planes at 4am where he's highest aog
oh my god oh i was gone
and i was i i usually eat at the airport
i was too high to even stay
so i'm just going to sit right here and
my
help you [ __ ] and i'm like what
the [ __ ]
awesome the door swings open on gate 89.
i tell you about this like you told me
but i didn't know i didn't know he came
from the like the tarmac okay for the
tarmac oh no i do what crawling on his
arms
he's like you [ __ ] left me
united you [ __ ] i hate you you
[ __ ] left me down there austin
there's three employees two black two
black dudes and a uh a black dude a
black shirt crazy and a white dude run
to him and they pick him up he's like
get the [ __ ] off me you son of a [ __ ]
i'm gonna sue you and he's young this is
on the plane this is no no outs still in
the airport it's still in the airport
only a couple of people saying this
because they're the gate was empty 88
and 89 were everywhere
85 was with my gate which had a few
people i was early as [ __ ]
i was early as [ __ ] i'm stoned as [ __ ]
and i found this vaping pen that [ __ ]
me up i was smoking on the way in the
uber
so i get to the airport i'm on fire and
comes this dude the black dude runs down
gets the guy's wheelchair obviously the
ramp agent left him down there and said
i'll come right back for you and they
closed the door and [ __ ] and left him
there he tipped the wheelchair over and
crawled up the ramp no
listen this is [ __ ] crazy
so they get him in his wheelchair he's
like [ __ ] you and they're like look is
there anything we can do for you because
you made me miss my ride and he's
yelling at him
i'm sorry
he's yelling at him he's yelling at him
finally i go this [ __ ] guy's gonna go
to jail
and he wasn't he was white
he was a nice white dude i went and i
bought a water for [ __ ] four bucks
and i brought it to him and i grabbed
his arm and in his ear i whispered i go
you're gonna go to jail
stop cursing it's a federal [ __ ]
building
they're gonna throw you in jail i don't
give a [ __ ] but he was he's white so
he's going i don't give a [ __ ]
and he's yelling towards them like white
people do like yeah trying to yell
towards them like that he can get away
at this time
[ __ ] them after what they did to me they
left me he was like one of those rambo
white people they left me
he was such a sweet white dude that's
what i'm trying to say to you and he
goes i just came to san antonio i
visited my kids they ruined my [ __ ]
vacation i'm in a home here for people
that are [ __ ] up
and he's a vet and stuff and he goes now
i don't know how i'm going to get home
and he's yelling and screaming i had a
yard sticking 220's i just gave the
220's
and i pushed him a little bit he said
thank you ended up being from new jersey
the dude
from like some part of the jersey in the
middle and we ended up talking a little
bit and then i saw some dude on the cart
and i go can you give him a ride please
in the game of [ __ ] ride
i get to [ __ ] cleveland
i walk into cleveland airport i'm
excited
i'm like i'm here you know what i'm
saying i go to the hotel the two
producers were on the plane with me i
was talking to them the writers of the
show i pitched they were on the plane
going to meet with the brown so i said
let's meet somewhere call me when i get
to the hotel i walked into that airport
when i saw welcome to cleveland i was
like the fort lauderdale shooter
i went in my pocket and took the last
star and popped it right under the
welcome to cleveland's song oh my god oh
my god get to the hotel i check in i go
to my room
for some reason every time i fly i feel
dirty so i always get off the plane yeah
wash my [ __ ] i check
pizza
yeah you just feel dirty i don't like
getting off a plane you feel so gross no
matter what it could be a 30 minute
flight you feel disgusting let me go
home watch my [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah clean my
ass right i couldn't even [ __ ] this
morning before the flight i was nervous
i wasn't going to make the airport so i
just cancelled it now you got to fly and
drop little farts every 20 minutes and
you can smell that
death coming out of your muffler you're
like where's tushy when they're your
seat doesn't decline you're in front of
the toilet you hear everyone [ __ ]
for some reason kate i went against the
grain like i'm not gonna take a shower
i'm gonna unpack a little bit and i took
my sleep apnea machine done i put it on
the counter oh no i plugged it in and
when i went to plug the back and i went
i saw sparks coming out of the wire go
oh no oh
and i look at it again and i try to plug
it from a different angle and it goes
again i try to put the wires together
it's going to just right right on me i'm
like oh no
i called the [ __ ] hotel maintenance
dude like do you have an electrician on
staff because yes we do he comes up he's
half [ __ ] you know he got hit in the
head with a missile in some [ __ ]
country
he's like well he can't put tape on it i
go give me the [ __ ] tape
i tried the tape and it wouldn't work my
body went into shock
my whole physical mental being i always
knew one day that that day would come
when that machine was gonna break oh god
it's so scary
so can you not sleep without it here's
the deal it's
i fall asleep all the time i fell asleep
on the plane yesterday there's nights i
fall asleep in the living room if i'm
sitting and there's an angle i can fall
asleep if i put pillows up in bed i
could fall asleep you can fall asleep
the problem was i didn't have the
machine
if you came over tonight and said joey
try to sleep i see it's mental it's just
mental yeah i became mental and from six
to nine i ate i got i said you know what
i called the doctors it was six o'clock
cleveland time there was nothing you can
do
but now i found out there's a service
that you joined
and it's 24 7.
you call them within an hour your
machine is there they know the machine
for you that's amazing so i go to the
restaurant the barbecue restaurant that
mabel's place it was [ __ ] delicious i
got a brisket sandwich
and i got the baked beans with the
jalapenos and the brisket in it
jesus christ
i'm getting hungry
when you told me that i thought you were
trying to eat heavy to fall asleep no i
went back though oh my god the brisket
sandwich wasn't that big no no it was a
designer restaurant it wasn't like a
place in austin it was delicious that's
a good idea though to eat heavy to fall
asleep yeah that's what i was thinking
that's a good plan back to my hotel room
and just panicked and panicked and
panicked and panicked i called the
doctors nobody returned the call
by nine o'clock
had become a reality you know and it's
like when you have that last cigarette
you could fall asleep it's when that
cigarette is gone and it's really tough
and in my world it's like being a coke
fiend and somebody blew up colombia yeah
yeah yeah
like at nine o'clock that's what it was
you can't get coke you literally can't
sleep without your machine and now it
started messing with my head
really like
so it wasn't like i i imagined i had
radio at six
oh you know guys are you afraid of
falling asleep because you stopped
breathing right now stop breathing but
if i put enough pillows and [ __ ] and put
the tv on and sit in a certain position
i could fall asleep i've lost a hundred
pounds since the sleep apnea i'm
breathing a lot better
so all these things come into effect
it's not the sleep apnea even though i
had a really bad case of it it's not the
sleep happening i had
when i walked in there you know and a
lot of it i blame on the jiu jitsu the
jiu jitsu has really helped me
overcome the fear of being on my back
that back
when you have really severe sleep apnea
you basically wake up on your ass every
night you feel like you're suffocating
you wake up like god
you wake up holding your chest
breathing like if somebody choked you
and you're about to [ __ ] die and it
gets right and it goes like every
[ __ ] 15 minutes i remember taking at
one point when it got really bad i would
take
four tylenol rpms that could knock out a
[ __ ] gorilla
wow and the sleep apnea wouldn't allow
the tylenols to let me go to sleep oh
you got to be so tense it's like your
anxiety kicks out i would just smoke
cigarettes stay up and fall asleep
smoking cigarettes there'd be burn marks
all over the carpet i never planted the
carp i had to replace the carpet falling
all the carpet in that living room
because
all the cigarettes i fell asleep
watching tv my wife and i didn't get up
yeah never caught fire no no no the
sleep apnea i had was horrible because i
was compounding it with drug use i
wasn't taking care of myself my diet was
bad i mean everything was bad about it
so
that's why when i went to jiu jitsu
that was the closest thing that i'd
experienced to sleep at me and i said i
can't let this beat me anymore so now i
can breathe on my back i don't panic
that's awesome that's awesome
but still the other night
by three o'clock kane i can't tell you
what i felt like because i actually took
a pillow
and put a laundry bag around it put the
shower on real hot and i just went in
the shower because in the old days i
could fall asleep in the shower when i
first had sleep apnea really yeah in the
shower the steam would open everything
up and the slant of the shower
that i guess that makes sense yeah so
the shower no matter how it is some tubs
of designer tubs and there's a big slam
yeah it's like getting a massage as
you're falling asleep sometimes
actually it sounds kind of great yeah i
would fall asleep in the tub i might
start doing that it looks like my
homemade water the reason why i never
moved out of hollywood wasn't because it
was because it was rent controlled i had
parking
and it had a boiler the size of
godzilla's dick
you could go to somebody's house and
have a three million dollar home and you
take a shower and after 10 minutes yeah
always it's always why i have a three
million dollar house if you have no
water yeah
i never understood that that always
happened
same at hotels you ever noticed the more
expensive the hotel is the less time the
hot water works what the [ __ ] is that
i've sat in those hotels for three
[ __ ] hours waiting that's no that's
why he there's no hot water for you
because at 7 00 am he takes a three-hour
hot shower i [ __ ] go there should be
enough people at the ritz carlton for
everyone to take a three-hour [ __ ]
shower all day every day
i will keep going to that south point
casino until i do until they have me
they have the best showers they have the
best shot they do i would drive off the
strip i'll stay 15 minutes off the strip
for that [ __ ] shower let me tell you
something that walk-in shower with the
water hitting you from the top and the
side walls
and the shower and you just i get super
[ __ ] high i'll eat five stars just to
take a shot how great is the shower i
just know i like
[Music]
listen here's the lineup
you get up in the morning you drink a
little coffee
right after like 15 minutes to get the
appetite going for the eggs and the
bacon you just take two hits off the
magic pipe and you just sit tight you
smoke some you drink some more coffee
you pop the nicotine gum you get wait
i'm sorry the magic pipe sure that's
that's weed yeah oh okay just checking
just trying to keep track of the doesn't
have to be killing my first
experience you just want two little hits
to open up your mind nice and early at 7
00 30. i don't want you to pass out 6 30
5 15 whenever your day starts i'd like
to take my mind back to them
the roughest times for me were being
young
when we were too stupid to understand
why you didn't get up 15 minutes before
you had to be there
up to the eighth grade was so stupid
because we have to be at school 8 30 and
we want to get up at 8 and just go to
school of course you know all [ __ ] up
but you as you get older you don't
realize
that hour and a half before
just to sit
realize why the [ __ ] you're doing this
realize why god put you on this planet
and also i need i
that's the real reason i get up extra
early have the coffee time to get up in
the morning and smoke a little bit just
a little bit
two hits put the joint out
go do some [ __ ]
just get your day started right out your
day what you want to do what your
aspirations are
and then you make breakfast
and then after breakfast you [ __ ]
take two bigger hits
and then you lay your clothes out
and then you jump in the shower and
while you're in the shower you're
plotting your [ __ ] takeover you see
i'm saying that's it
if you're legit you bang one out if
there's nobody around you're banging out
of that respect i've never done that in
the shower maybe you should start oh you
come on your feet you don't know what
life is like you come on your feet wait
you've never banged one out in the
shower no i always did it behind my bed
it's disgusting what
yeah i don't know a better better like a
desk chair the shower though just kind
of gets me in the mood to do it
sometimes i'm not a dude i mean maybe
it's different maybe the shower's not no
you're there you might as well you
shaved you shampooed yeah you bubbled up
you said everything you had to do you
might as well bang on that house
no regrets
don't think i'm not masturbating in the
morning i'm i'm jacking up oh no one
thinks that yeah no one knowing everyone
knows when you get dressed you go in the
[ __ ] car you start your car your car
warms up yeah take a breath you look
around you've already covered all your
bases
you had a nourishing breakfast you got
high you washed your [ __ ] you did
everything that was needed already by
9am i love it i love starting the day
with a with an orgasm i do every day
don't you what's that start the day with
an orgasm no
this is like when i'm in a hotel oh okay
i am done wanting sex that's it no well
i didn't say i forget you have another
person now so it's not the same i get
anxiety now
and the last couple times i've been
breathing too heavy and it's like you
know if you want a heart attack [ __ ]
around before
you have morning sex it makes your
anxiety worse all right
breathing heavy
the last three or four times it's [ __ ]
my world up in the morning oh i love it
i love eating monkey in the morning all
that [ __ ] but
it has given me so much like i get so
hot and bothered and my
my pulse goes up and i can't breathe
right this is the most comfortable
amazing reason i've ever heard from not
wanting to go oh my god i'm 50 [ __ ]
full my heart beats weird yeah the
reason he doesn't want to do it do you
think he's gonna have a heart attack
a heart attack you want to survive the
death most people have heart attacks
before lunch time he's like i want to
[ __ ] but i'd rather survive last time
that is the silliest rule you've had the
last time
yeah something happened to me like my
valve went crazy i don't know what the
[ __ ] happens i'm like that's it you know
i don't i'm not a huge fan i'm not a
huge fan of morning snacks
because this is the thing the only time
i want morning sex if it's like fake
morning sex where i kind of half woke up
while he was still sleeping and i
freshened myself up a little bit and
then came back and pretended to be
asleep and then we have it
otherwise i feel grungy and i don't like
it
all right so i give you a stab at night
you wash your monkey before you go to
bed you don't want your monkey to go to
bed with that condom juice on and [ __ ]
now you go to bed you wash your monkey
overnight it marinates just like a
turkey in thanksgiving thank you you
don't cook the turkey
[ __ ] you let it boil so when you wake
up in the morning your little monkey has
a little wang to it you understand that
like okay
okay just like a little different type
of wing like it smells like gun bottle
or something just let you know it's
there and the morning is tremendous
because you just touch it you can see it
get nice and wet the juices then you
grab that little
you rub that [ __ ] three fingers
deep you give her a three finger louie
and then
then you eat that monkey in the morning
and i gotta tell you something meat
monkey in the morning is topping that
what that's the best
i thought you were saying you didn't so
you loved the morning session oh i love
eating somebody's [ __ ] in the morning
for breakfast that's my world i thought
that was going in a whole other
direction i thought you were eating a
monkey after it's gross off monkey no no
i like it with a little whiff to it it's
gotta have some length to it in the
morning
that's why you got to work it and get
the old giza out of there because
you would like to have overnight
curmudgeony gum juice in there no no no
no no no take a shower and i in fact i'd
rather you go to bed without giving you
a stop
and you're laying there snoring i come
up from behind you take your little
panties i'll spread your legs yes lick
your [ __ ] a little bit i'll pop you
up and when i'm licking your hands so i
can actually watch your little [ __ ]
swell up you understand what that does
still man joey your [ __ ] dick
while you're eating that monkey you bang
one out yourself just to shoot that
first load out so you can last a little
bit and then while it's dead louie and
you're eating her monkey and it's nice
and wet you put that soldier in her
mouth fresh in the morning with bad
breath and everything i don't give a
[ __ ] my soldier likes bad breath in the
morning you suck that monkey hard and
now that soldier's hard your monkey's
wet why you're sucking my monkey i'm
fingerprinted
louie and i got a pinky in your [ __ ]
because i got dexterity three finger
losers and then i switch back i flip you
around and i bang you from behind it
takes a minute you come fast i come fast
and the party's over now we take showers
you make oatmeal everybody goes to work
it's kind of turning me on a little it
has to come young
way before the white hair is [ __ ] damn
you have to have secrets i wasn't good
at sex at night but in the morning
somebody eat your [ __ ] and eat your
[ __ ] for breakfast your whole day is
dead like wow joey's not my type but
there's something about him hang on i
gotta change my plans for tomorrow he's
gonna say okay
kate's outside clutching her heart with
that dog that's the whole pathwand oh my
god
the morning is real lovely you're gonna
do it like that in the morning you
should do it every morning that's that's
the whole thing man the [ __ ] leaks more
when you look at the sheet there's a
little circle under it you can change my
whole outlook on mourning yourself put
your finger in it it's getting that
juice out of it
what the [ __ ] do you guys think you're
dealing with i've been around the world
three [ __ ] times
[ __ ] i'm just i was never [ __ ] you
know when you're not a handsome dude you
gotta work it from different [ __ ]
angles the great thomas ward had a joke
that he wasn't a good piece of ads
joey's giving a sex workshop today by
the way
the great thomas ward a comedian friend
of ours from the store used to have one
of my all-time favorite jokes that he
wasn't good in bed but a lot of [ __ ]
would happen he was [ __ ] you know
he'd break windows
and light fires i think joe you should
start a teaching class at the learning
animals
moves for guys this is something that no
because even when you describe it it's
like reading a it's like reading 50
shades of grey dirty dirty dirty dude
from all that then when we had the sky
like the way you describe sex guys need
to learn okay about it
this could be a mission i almost said
quake yes why is it because if any other
guy said what he just said it'd be
creepy he'd be so creepy why is it okay
for him because he's a casanova
looks like he has a nobody i don't got
that like you've got that like suave
like
italian
sexy like
the voice those years of doing blow
is really like parts of it with
disgusting sex
but parts of it were really sexy like i
got to learn a lot about what women were
made of
like it's not just giving head and
whatever yeah there's so many women it's
like when a woman's vagina opens up to
you and it gets warm
like there's a woman's love like when
you pull their hair from a ponytail and
the hair goes down straight the way
you're wearing it now
there's so many different looks of a
woman you know
there really is when you're making a
leptin it's [ __ ] tremendous man we're
gonna be the first podcast to get kicked
off of itunes
listen if you're talking about the truth
that can't kick you you pull the hair
i mean listen for real women in bed
all the respect flies out the window
women want you to be an animal
pick them up oh suck that pipe that's
the best when they look at you and they
go pipe right [ __ ] suck that point
shut the [ __ ] up do another line of coke
by the way
speaking of uh sucking the the
pipe
uh you know last time i was on here you
spoke about that
about the anal sex yeah did i tell you i
was in las vegas and the anal sex story
by the way never had more phone calls
from family do you know how widespread
your show is
people heard your show that i'm like how
is my great grandmother in idaho listen
it was amazing yeah but uh i ran into
these two guys in vegas they come up to
me and they were like hey
are you kate it was like three in the
morning in a casino and i was like yeah
and they were like oh my god
we watched you on uh on joey diaz
podcast can we buy you a drink and i
wasn't trying to like hook up or
anything so i was like oh thanks i'm
cool but i'm good but thanks a lot and
they were like no no we're not trying to
bang you he goes the one guy goes i just
wanted to thank you personally because
you're the reason my girlfriend let me
try anal
and i was like wait that's that's my
life
that's what you took away these [ __ ]
animals will bring these podcasts and
make their girlfriends listen to it and
go see i told you yeah i told you it's
fun to do it in the ass and you're like
oh my god guys they come to shows and
tell me
we did the pigeon we did the whole thing
i'm okay with i felt like i felt like
okay with that like i felt like that was
my big contribution to his life because
he got his girlfriend on board
and you know it and they seem happy
from that there's a scene in there
there's a scene in the department you
receive departed with jack nicholson
yeah actually i don't think and there's
a scene of the party where they're doing
opera there's an opera scene
and jack nicholson has a hot girlfriend
but that night he brings his girlfriend
to the black shade
and they're banging each other they show
a scene of them banging each other table
he's got a bowl filled with coke
remember that scene lee
and he's like you girls want to do coke
let's do some [ __ ] coke and he just
starts throwing the coke out
and just that looks so [ __ ] sexy just
to throw the coke at you and just lick
you with that [ __ ] coke how is this
happening lines off your [ __ ] stomach
and off your legs and puts them on your
clinton number and then go back to it
and work just the fact that jack
nicholson turned you on
jack nicholson throwing coke at the
black chick and the white chicken that
naked in bed yeah he's got a robot he
just walks and he goes you girls on that
you can see they did makeup on him they
did his eyebrows to make him look evil
for the scene like coked up
and he goes you girls want to get do
coke let's do some coke here's some cut
he just starts whipping it with the coke
and i was like i could see myself in
[ __ ] 87 doing something freaky like
i mean
sure who wouldn't oh my god how funny
how something about me brings out the uh
the the old sex stories in you well no
no because we're talking about all that
disgust though [ __ ] disgusting yeah yeah
it's all disgust though that's the
cocaine disgusto
talk
what about [ __ ] you said that you had
ran into a friend who [ __ ] her pants in
bed or what no no no i didn't have a
friend she was an acquaintance
she lived in she lived and she lived in
l.a
and i knew her and one day i said what
happened she was working no more and
they said
somebody [ __ ] her in the ass she [ __ ]
the bed
he was a comedian he told everybody and
she got so embarrassed
she moved i don't know the exact thing i
would move out of the country i don't
know if that's even the real reason i
just had to be i would move to another
state if i [ __ ] the i would be so
embarrassed
i don't think i could ever face anyone
because you know how the comedy
community it's so small oh yeah i can't
that's why i said you can't do nothing
with a [ __ ] comic like get off no if
you [ __ ] the bed that is getting yeah oh
that's getting around everybody's we're
a hug
you have to leave you can't stay after
that not that story i [ __ ] my pants at
ventura harbor club did i tell you that
no yeah on stage uh not well very close
i was headlining vents for a hardwood
club
the guy going up before me had like
three minutes to go
and uh i've been taking this herbal
supplement for my anxiety
and so it's just take xanax like
everybody else in [ __ ] hollywood
i don't want to i want to i don't want
to get addicted to it it freaks me out
i i probably should do that but look i
get crazy like i'm a little i get a
little like too giddy when i'm that's
fine i'd rather you get even
having anxiety
yeah i know well i got this stuff though
so it's just it's like um
citric acid but like in a powder form
and it's supposed to calm you down
so that
last couple days i was starting to feel
really anxious
and on my way to ventura harbor club i
called my friend and was like i got bad
anxiety today and she was like have you
been taking the calming powder and i was
like i forgot the last couple days that
must be it i'll take extra oh no so i
made a bottle of water like this big and
i put like half of the does it change
color the water yeah it turns orange and
you shake it up you're only supposed to
have a teaspoon i put in like half a
water bottle worth i drank it on the way
to ventura harbor club
and then when i got there
i was like man i feel great i'm so calm
and then i'm like i'm so calm i need a
pick-me-upper so i got a cup of coffee
yeah it sizzled that [ __ ] the
dude on stage has three minutes left i
take a sip of the coffee and my stomach
starts to turn yeah that's it but i
don't want to go to the bathroom because
he only has three minutes i'm like what
if he comes off a minute early so i
tried to stand there and wait
and then
i started to get a really bad
stomachache like not be able to go on
stage stomachache and then i didn't know
what to do so i was like well maybe it's
it's gas i'll try and like pass gas and
then i tried to fart
and a little little turn flew out of
there
wet or dry
how long did you have to stay on stage
your daughter no no no so then i ran to
the bathroom it gets worse joey this is
so embarrassing
what's the audience saying there's still
the guy on stage is like a minute no one
knows this is happening yet i haven't
gone on stage yet i'm waiting in the
back he's still got like a minute to go
so i run to the bathroom
i get in there and it's like it's like
you know when you let a little bit out a
lot wants to come out it's like the
floodgates are open so i pull my pants
down i sit down i'm [ __ ] my pants
and then i realized that i had worn this
shirt that's like trendy it's like short
in the front long in the back so when i
sat down to
the bottom of the shirt
in the toilet it's a white shirt now
it's covered in [ __ ] so
that i have like under a minute so i'm
splashing the shirt in the sink i'm
trying to clean it up i'm trying to
clean up my pants because there's a
little poop in my pants and
i'm trying to clean up and then i hear
the guy on stage like you ready for your
headline or you've seen her on whatever
i wasn't even in the room so i pulled my
pants up they're still wet tucked the
back of my shitty shirt into my jeans
and run out on stage and had to do 40
minutes
with shitty pants and i was wondering
the whole time like can i wonder if they
can
surely smell it
i didn't know it did and then afterwards
i had to stay and judge a costume
contest it was halloween how long have
you had anxiety for
um
really not bad until the last few years
i think it's this business did you ever
take medication for it no
i started getting it
just before i quit blow and then once i
switched the reefer i was good like once
i started smoking reefer reefer reefer
and i didn't do any drugs
the anxiety went away and it started
coming back about two years ago at the
comedy store i get anxiety when i go to
the camp right before i go on stage
my world spins around i wonder why but
then
i started getting into other places i
got at the wilbur theater
i got in connecticut a little bit yeah
when i shot the special the first show i
got it
the second show i didn't get it so it's
kind of weird how you really it comes
and goes like i try not to do edibles
now
so i that's why i'm asking because i
suffer from the same thing usually
before i get on stage if it's my stomach
you cut one of those farts one of those
[ __ ] before you [ __ ] your pants egg
hurts oh it's hard and you're standing
in the back of the store and people are
saying oh my god what's that smell and
you're like i know
yeah and then looking around
that's from anxiety that's that last
thing that's your anxiety sometimes i'll
blow a fart
just to get me out of the
that's a good thing you're not taking
the the powder that i'm taking or you'd
be [ __ ] your pants
every time when i got together with my
acupuncturist ten years ago right the
first cheetah she goes you have to clean
out your intestines you know i want you
to do this she would treat me for
different things every other tuesday
so some tuesdays it would be my adrenals
yeah with my lungs another tuesday she
would clean my liver and my intestines
and stuff like that
she gave me this powder one time you
know like when you get ramen that
package the flavor powder sure it was
the same size package okay and she told
me she goes i want you to empty the
package out like you're doing coke and
cut it in half and put
half and snort it into a gallon of water
measure the gal now she goes no more no
less don't play with this stuff these
are chinese herbs
i put half of it in there and nothing
happened to the water
so she's got to be wrong i put the whole
thing in oh my god what happened what
you just said to me on stage on the way
there oh [ __ ] on the way home two hours
after that
yeah it just broke down my intestines
i mean it was like a liquid on stage i
sneezed and that was like a little
liquid and that was it she probably gave
me what i'm taking i ran out of that
comedy store i got back in that car on
the way home at a light i sneezed again
a little bit and they could hear it like
you know you you know when you put your
cup in the mcdonald's and you go into
the thing of 7-eleven and it hits like
like that's what was coming out of my
muffler like oh i still remember also on
highland i was on the highland and
fountain
and i was almost home and i had to run
in my wife's like what's that smell was
it oh my god you don't want to know the
cops i told you some [ __ ] story
my pants were brown i had to go back
downstairs that night open the car oh my
god after i closed it which smelled
hard and i had a spray like interior
armoire i had to wash it
i don't believe the windows open the car
smelled terrible i didn't [ __ ] in the
car seat but just me sitting on this
[ __ ] in my pants on top of the car seat
made that cost smell like death
that was the only bad experience i've
had on stage this is making my
experience seem not as bad yeah because
i don't think my car didn't smell like
[ __ ] i didn't have to get it deep so did
you clean it you clean well i cleaned it
i mean i cleaned it out before i left
the club as best i could
i always carry summer's eve wipes just
in case anyway they're tremendous i
really do i keep them in my purse
because i'm always like you just never
know like i always try to make sure if
anyone's going to be in that area that
i've showered right before like i'm a
right before shower but if i have to
come from somewhere else i'd keep the
summer's eboy that's when i used to date
this girl one day i ran on the soap and
i used the summer's eve vaginal scrub
and i used to buy it on the road because
it made everything shinier down there
everything cleaner down there my helmet
doesn't really shine oh my god smoking
even my skin even the turtleneck skin
that looks like i got hit by a car
i met women not mad wait
oh my god it's it's like yeah it's a
it's approved by gynocologists and it's
vagina soap but i'm telling you
something like if it clean if it cleans
out a dirty vagina could you imagine
looking through your
yes it does it develops a fungi and
mushrooms like lee ate tonight and
that's what happens over time
trust me even gravity holds stuff
forever for a long time you think
there's back there's back semen from
like two
oh my god disgusting what are we even
talking about what the [ __ ] knows this
is why it's a podcast if i if i wanted
to talk about something significant i'd
be on tv if somebody wanted to hear this
[ __ ] they'd put me on [ __ ] world news
tonight and we could tell maury schaefer
yeah i don't [ __ ] know i mean
i think the gravity holds some stuff in
the middle
you're really thinking about it yeah
because it's true
oh how did we get here there's certain
women that you date that after you date
them your helmet smells a certain way no
yeah i used to date this girl for like
two years wait a second for how long and
every time i'd bang her i'd smell my
helmet how do you smell your hair
how
and then in the mornings i would wake up
and smell my helmet and it would smell
like a monkey even when i was in weather
the night before
no
yeah
had you just not taken a shower since
you you don't need though i don't want
to know what guy gets up in the morning
and smells it no one i've never heard
you gotta know
i love this because i i think that all
girls should do a little taste test yeah
but i've never heard of a guy doing like
what woman have you taken home that
before you're gonna dig into the monkey
she goes hold on let me go pee she don't
have to pee she's gotta go double check
and make sure everything's cleaned out
and there's no skid marks yeah there's
no whole [ __ ] head down there there's
no [ __ ] time i mean i guess women she
doesn't finger herself and smell i don't
think women will scratch us a little bit
i just won't hook up if i know that's
happening like like if i'm out somewhere
and i meet someone and i just had a
shower and nothing has happened between
the shower and then then i don't mind
but if there's any chance of anything
going on down there like when you go to
ballet
with that [ __ ] little floor like a
little ballet shoe smell to it that
little that little yoga pant wang to it
i wouldn't make you directly come home
don't go no don't stop and settle in for
cigarette don't do nothing
come home where are these men
where are these guys little panties that
squeeze
a little bit of hair to your little joey
joey joey it's done it's like pearl
harbor it's going down you know what i'm
saying it smells so dark you're [ __ ]
you're japan i'm godzilla you know what
i'm talking about
i can't handle that
what the [ __ ] i love how he said that's
when that's when guys want to eat your
[ __ ] that's when a guy wants to eat
your [ __ ] they don't let you [ __ ] when
you're clean let's be honest listen
every man wants you to go to ballet they
want you to run an hour no no man's ever
actually asked me to go to ballet
bells for an hour and come back and see
me with that dirty monkey from the night
before a little grind like if you got up
in the morning and just went right to
kettlebell class right from kettlebell
home no let me eat that little swamp
with that yeah i think uh that's
definitely not something women are
looking for just want to put that out
but that's what guys like they want to
get that fresh wang i think that guys
yes thank you
to say that no woman wants a swamp of
anything no they don't it's not a lot of
wings
in your mind you think there's a lot of
wing to it but there's really not a lot
of wing to it it's got a little sweat to
it and that's it you pull the sweat
beads aside you got different
definitions away
i'm like wait we just changed sexes i'm
so [ __ ] up
you dive in like a hawk of death you
understand
yes that's the truth what the [ __ ] are
we talking about where's tony bennett
dude
okay
thank god for tony bennett in time
probably no probably we're the same
what's a bunga
no you're gonna finish that chocolate
give it to leo no no no no no no no you
want it
no i don't know
it's 10 milligrams come on at this point
who cares
[Music]
and bring it back to us
bring it back to us
you call first dance
dog it's monday night [ __ ] what
do you want from me let me give some
shout outs to our kate todd here first
of all honey i love you today
thank you for the steel bells my
shoulders are loose everything's
beautiful
i can't give you a deal on the steel
bells but i give you a deal on the
protein powder and the alpha brain and
the shroom type
and that's what i believe in brother
that's one of the two of those shroom
techs before jiu jitsu i know a kid who
eats four of them drinks a cup of coffee
and goes to jiu jitsu and he flies to
the [ __ ] air like a ringling brother
and then he got
r.i.p
and then that two ringling brothers
that's all over the elephant they
shouldn't have whipped the elephants and
[ __ ] they were beating those [ __ ]
gorillas and the elephants and the
tigers and now they're out of business
but [ __ ] uh
i wasn't talking about it
on it yeah on it i love you shroom tech
support shroom tech immune i [ __ ]
love it man
alpha brain when i fly the hemp force
protein
in the morning are you [ __ ] kidding
me or what 20 of life no parole go to
honda.com right now and press in church
bam and get 10 percent off your order
delivered to your house how about mr 508
and gc
coverley and casual d e
and j rama
and bobby sharon happy birthday you bad
[ __ ] your wife made you some
[ __ ] steak with raspberry sauce who's
better than you richard mcmanus
nick smith
the la lingas family in chicago north
shore scott and pamela
i don't know pamela gray this one let me
sniff your finger will you you filthy
yeah i'd sit around me you're gonna
stand there like [ __ ] superwoman
with dirty fingers
did you wash your hands yeah good good
that's what guys want they don't want a
clean monkey that's in the movies oh my
god they wanted to have like an odor to
it like a not an older like i like
gunpowder
i used to date a certain woman that
he'll monkey smell like gunpowd like
with somebody little gun powder can you
bring some gunpowder in so i can have
some like i don't know what gunpowder
smells like i guess not when you are a
kid when you were a kid did you ever
play with those rocks you quacked
together and they smelled like gun smoke
yeah but i've never had a vagina that
smell like that listen if you date a
woman a monkey smells like gum pilot
keeper
so what's going on in your life kate
beside what's going on with comedy and
the tv the playboy show uh oh the
playboy show has been great this season
uh it's called undercover if you guys
haven't seen it it's uh
this season was really fun we got into
some dope [ __ ] how many episodes you
shoot we shot 12 uh 12 both seasons
that was dope angelo was in here they
cancelled that radio show i know i love
that girl i like it too man they it was
the playboy morning show i guess they're
doing away with like live studio shows
it sounds like they're trying to make
the the whole network more funny and a
little more mainstream uh so i don't
know
i don't know if that's why they're doing
it but
it's weird and you have an agent and you
go out on the road every week which is
good i see you hustling i try
i don't know you know what's weird about
this business i mean you've been in it
way longer than me but it's like it's
crazy how
i'll be hustling and hustling and
hustling and then a whole bunch of stuff
happens and then all of a sudden you hit
like
a wall where it's just slow as [ __ ] or
nothing's happening and for me like
we're talking about anxiety it drives
you crazy yeah
even if it's just a week even it's just
one week i look at my schedule a week
from christmas to new year's i was
suicidal yeah suicidal we did a podcast
on
the 26th
and the rest of the week the baby didn't
go to school and the phone didn't ring
and i thought i was gonna [ __ ] shoot
myself yeah i get anxiety also i'm like
you i get what's up but i get
you know it's it's weird because you've
been here for 10 years
and you have to this is why i was
telling lee and i were having this
conversation that
it's like when you tell a market
okay we're telemarketers we just tell
the market comedy yeah okay that's yeah
pretty much this is this is basically it
so right now you're a feature act and
you're calling hilarity's in the tempi
improv
thank god
you're funny and people see what i what
i see in you so
i had a week that was close you know i
didn't want to compromise you i know
that you do tv work or something
happened
you could drive back to tempe so i asked
you
but you know you're never a woman to
complain you know uh you're never a
woman to say that i'm giving me spots
here or there's only
you know come to the store they only
they don't give women spots then go
somewhere else
they go somewhere else if you're worried
about not spots at the store you're not
worried you lost the mission you lost
the mission just to do [ __ ] spots and
you also you can find them and you can
make your own [ __ ] now i see you in
ontario i see you driving to [ __ ]
mars on a daily every night i see you i
mean i just like at the end of the day
it's fun there's nowhere i'd rather be
you know how it is i mean it's like the
time that you spend on stage it's uh
exhilarating and i mean so
i feel so lucky to get to do this for a
job and that's why i work so hard
because i recognize like when i go home
and i see people doing the same jobs
they were doing when i left
ohio when i was like 19. i'm like god
i'm so lucky like even on the times that
are slow or i'm not working that much
i'm like
this is still like an awesome job at the
end of the day and you're here you're
here in the game that people dream of
like
dream of being here and you're here
people talk to you you have an agent
i feel so lucky all the time like i tell
the utel market comedy so i totally we
don't have a day off in this life
days off for people that are worried and
regular yeah or animals of death there's
no days off because that day off you're
gonna have a day off later because you
didn't make calls that day
that's why you did those three days
because those that day you didn't make
any calls if you always have claws in
the pipe always if you if you have six
things in the pipe you gotta assume five
of them are gonna go go under come on
man we're not [ __ ] geniuses here you
just gotta be on the hustler
i'm sorry and
here's here's something i've been
struggling with okay so you get busy
right how it's hard what what i've been
struggling with is maintaining going out
there and getting more for the
followings like this week i'm kind of
slow because last week we got super busy
and then yeah i have time well in time
you're going to learn how to mix both of
them yeah that is hard though you're
going to learn how to do work in the
morning and in the afternoons do that
little hustle
or you find enough success to where you
can hire some help with that like i uh
when i was shooting my tv show the first
season and i was by no means making a
lot of money but i was super busy and i
couldn't get back to everybody to set
stuff up for when it was over and so i
hired somebody to help me and like i'm
saying this this sounds almost like so
hollywood and braggy to me like i hired
someone to help because i was busy but
it helped
i spent almost nothing on it like i
found this lady that was willing to do
it for super cheap it helped my anxiety
helped me get organized it helped me
like plan ahead and now
i'm
i'm a huge fan of like
spending money on someone to help you
absolutely it's
i i was always do it myself like even in
school i wanted to do projects by myself
but recently it's like
well you have to treat this as a
one-person business and businesses
sometimes get assistance or or people to
help out and like it feels weird you
don't want to be like oh i'm going to
sit
yeah it sounds douchey in l.a and people
assume that if you have one that you're
making a lot of money but for me it was
like i would actually rather not go out
as much not have as much cool clothes
not have cool purses and stuff but spend
the money on that just make my whole
life better there's this guy that i've
been working with a music guy and he
he's really opened my eyes to that
because he goes like he just went to
cuba his name is john fulford he he went
and he he hired like these cuban
musicians on the street and just
recorded an album with him and then he
goes and then he goes and he flies to
albania to do like a record a deal
because he like distributes music or
something
and he he like flies it just to do a
meeting and it's like
you
you're hoarding money almost when you
start start out because you're so broke
but you have it's almost like spend
money to make money you have to have it
to just put yourself out there yeah
if you can find a way or
even like a lot of like uh interns you
know they just want to learn about the
business or
i'm very selfish
i don't
my wife helps me to a degree
lee helps me to a degree
but there's
a degree that
i can't explain to lee what i'm doing it
would take me too long
you know i call lee after i do the work
and i try i switch your saying this is
what yeah you can't explain we call this
chick we set this lady up yeah playing
games with this lady
it's amazing yeah i don't have time to
sit lee down at eight in the morning
because it would take me we have to come
over at seven if i got an assistant i
have to come over at seven to six i see
what you're saying and my day is just
remember which i don't have the time i
wish i did but what if she was just you
were paying her for like a certain
number of hours and then as [ __ ] just
popped in your head you hit her up and
we're like oh write this down right like
i'm so disorganized i almost just needed
like it's almost like paying a mom
you need an assistant for other stuff
you can you can handle your own business
i think that people would realize how
like lee says
lee said something last week that my
wife has said
and i can't let that get out
lee said to me the other day i tell my
wife all the time how crazy you are
i'm crazy though
i'm crazy but i know we're going in
yeah i'm not crazy in the background
crazy
you know what i'm crazy
when you're [ __ ] around
that's what i'm thinking this [ __ ]
years ago when i was out at 10 o'clock
doing blood i would think of [ __ ] and
never do anything with it
now
when i think of something
like
there's times all right i had a friend
growing up his name was anthony
anthony was a great kid
but anthony had the family business
so when you were 16 and you were
thinking about concerts and you would
call anthony and look at him
anthony's mind would be somewhere else
because he had to pick up a body and yes
so we started calling him gearhead
because the gears were always going
and you know and if you smelt smoke that
means he was really like he was really
thinking yeah you know and there's
people like when i'm when i get up at i
can what if i go to bed at eight tonight
i get so high
and and lee knows i think you know past
eight already knows that i would go home
on a tuesday night and stay in
and at 3 30 i'll call lee and go lee
look at what we're gonna do tomorrow
like like it's nine in the morning at 3
30 in the morning oh yeah yeah because
this is what we're doing sure this is
the plan of attacking lee's like hold on
one second he's awake that's a great
he'll get up
tomorrow
the first year of this podcast we were
working on
we were working on i remember still
calling them one night at midnight
they're saying i'm sorry
it's late sorry to call and leave once
lee said it's okay are a champion you
have an idea call me we're family no way
this is what people do lee i need you in
my life people can get you there he's
the type of guy that'll call me a four
and go i thought or something i think
you should do this here and it's a
brilliant idea but it took to get up at
four in the [ __ ] morning yeah if i
have to bury that idea
and save it to you on monday for the
presentation all right i don't have time
for that [ __ ]
i would need an all hours person
and when it's got to be done guess what
it's got to be done this is what needs
to be done maybe you can get an alexa so
then it needs to be done you get like a
amazon alexa
i don't have a manager
because if i got to call you to do your
[ __ ] job we're going to have a
problem and guess what i've been doing
your job just fine for 20 years and even
better than you would do it
you know you already see the movie
knows lee knows that i'll probably
attend and i think anybody who's
representing me by the time they get in
at nine they got three emails from me
instructing them
on the move because sometimes it's not
telling people what to do
it's the move that people don't
understand i don't have time to tell you
about the move till after you come to
i'm going to say you're right how did
you do this
nobody could get to him well
he goes to aaa
and he's friends with a friend of mine
that goes to hey my friend put the bug
in his ear you following me no i'm not
following you i don't have time to
explain this [ __ ] to you or nobody else
how i'm going to make the move
are you following my mind no it happens
all the time in a creepy criminal
elementary type of way when i say it to
you because it's like when i wanted the
movie the longest yard yeah it pissed me
off that they wouldn't read me what did
i do i was in houston texas i hired this
guy to tape me
with a [ __ ] football jersey on a
helmet
and i sent the tape to adam sandlin he
got it and they called me and they took
me to lunch
they weren't the star for that movie i
didn't give a [ __ ] that movie belonged
to me that's why because they were
looking at tony saragusa or big [ __ ]
from the sopranos they're not comedians
sorry i spit on your tit
they're not comedians no you didn't it
went right in the cleavage it was
tremendous no it didn't even if i was a
freak i couldn't spend your time
you saw it goes right in your little
titty there tremendous
you couldn't pay for somebody to spit in
your cleavage that's how good i am
anyway i don't even think that happened
i did not accept that i did not accept
that that is the best story i did not
accept that because at that time i was
following paul mooney at the comedy
store every night
and let me tell you something those guys
might have been a celebrity funny guy
but at that time i was following paul
mooney every [ __ ] night i would drive
to die
i don't know too many people that drive
to die
i was driving to dying and i would get
so pissed about doing that you wanted to
get better i resented even not thinking
that you wouldn't put me in your movie
i'm a real comic at the comedy at
buffalo at the halftime of the sabers
game and got booed that's a comedian
okay
and i stuck it out so when i made that
tape and sent it
like i was [ __ ] that
i believed that much of me you know what
i'm saying like it was that much belief
i couldn't teach somebody to do that by
the time i told my agent
when i got back was when i called my age
and i go you're not going to believe
what i did
and i think that happens all the time a
lot i mean because that well that's the
thing in this business by the time you
tell your agent
no no you can't sit around and wait for
that that's i think the biggest mistake
people make when they come out here they
get representation and then they just
sit and they wait
and now it's like with everything you
can do with social media
a podcast let me tell you what i did
yeah yeah i mean i just feel like it's
laziness and then i meet people that are
like well they don't get until 10 we'll
call them at nine yeah i guarantee
they're in the office they're jewish
they're in the office
i'll never forget i used my first
manager i was trying again i was a cuban
miami m probably just opened i would
call him every day at night did you get
me into the miami improv i called and
left the message she wants you to send
the team did you get me anytime i had my
improv yeah because i'm one of those
dudes that don't tell me about the tape
[ __ ]
yeah i hired you to do a [ __ ] job
i don't know
convince them yeah convince them they're
going to take what you are you need this
yeah and finally one day i called sarah
and she picked up the phone in the first
ring
i go saturday there's joey diaz i've
been driving in the club she goes hold
on let me get my date for you and she
gave me the dates and i called that
idiot
and i go hey man how are you i go did
you get a hold of sarah he goes no
she never answers the phone i go grab
the book
i'm in buffalo january 8th through
whatever and in miami the following week
and he [ __ ] his pants i fired him three
months later i was just gonna say i hope
you didn't i want them for a lot of how
i work yeah i mean if they're not i
don't know
when i need something i gotta dive in
there and i dive in a little different a
couple months ago i was on that tour
and they canceled the first four dates
where it was they weren't going to pay
nobody i heard a lot of people didn't
get paid oh yeah
i went to my age and i go listen bro
this is like me giving kate money for a
pound of weed from lee
a bad idea guess who just guess who's
responsible
on the street did this happen guess
who's responsible okay
you are
yeah you better give me the 800 for that
[ __ ] pound yeah
guess what i did i called the guy
directly like a man i said i got a wife
and a kid
i could either pay me that money or we
got to figure something out sure enough
he put me on the tour and he gave me
three nights no way even the lap
and my agent kept saying i don't know if
he's going to go for it i called him and
said i looked at the irvine schedule
looked a little on the [ __ ] white
side
that's what you have to do and he put me
on there you gotta put some salt just
gotta do it yourself always you just
gotta do it yourself i don't have
i don't have the confidence
i have the confidence and leave for a
lot of things lee knows but in some rock
and roll situations i i gotta rock and
roll dog
i gotta rock and roll this is gonna and
this always has to get done
yeah we gotta rock and roll we ain't got
time for church
[ __ ] every this comes first and that's
what most people don't understand
me i don't give a [ __ ] the worst thing
you could say is no get her on the stick
so if i got to tell you to get you know
situation happened a month ago with the
special with ciso yeah and i shut my
mouth i didn't say that when i got the
call from cesar the next day
that the special had been the number one
view special in the history of cso i
called the manager and told her
i knew they were gone at this point they
were on the fence 70 they were going i
fired them before oh wow but they kept
the imdb up and they kept getting calls
from me and we kept the relationship
i see and i decided that listen you guys
got to show up with something this
cannot be imdb central and i'm paying
you 10 points i don't need the reception
that's what i'm saying i don't think
they weren't doing anything you couldn't
do yourself i emailed the seesaw thing i
wanted her
i wanted her to think of the next move
and i gave it three days to think about
it she never did it and i knew right
there they were 80 off the gate then
they had one thing holding them to the
thing was that was december 19th they
were supposed to call me and they never
call them december 20th i said they're
gone
oh it was that easy in my mind the third
i picked up the phone and said i love
you the debt
off and then they were like ha ha and i
called her on monday and said do me a
favor get me off the [ __ ] imdb so
there's no misunderstanding i mean
that's the thing i don't i don't have
time for the kids they have to be i got
away from the kid dog initiating for the
kid yeah i need an assistant to do what
to go to the laundry for me am i that am
i that vain i need an assistant to do
what to vacuum
to come over and do what and listen to
me say what but what if you needed help
with just that stuff even like what if
you were like so what if you were single
and you were or no what if you were just
so crazy busy and you i don't know you
just the thoughts that come into my head
i'm a pot smoker for 30 years
the thoughts that come into my head for
business are like people that are
molested not people that are molested
people that have demented and hear
voices and [ __ ] that's how
this life comes into my head on a daily
basis
so i'll be sitting here going oh i gotta
go to nashville in two weeks
and all of a sudden i'll make a move
that at two in the afternoon they'll
just come to me
by the time i call kate and tell her
what the move is and why oh yeah i'm not
i don't think you need somebody for that
mundane of it yeah that's time yeah
that's crazy though yeah uh there's jobs
in hollywood that lia and i and somebody
else were on the show talking about this
three weeks ago that one day your show
is over
and you go to your account no as they
call them in la business manager another
two and a half percent out of your
paycheck right for somebody to pay your
bills yeah with a 50 50 percent that one
that they're going to disappear dane
cook's brother rob i don't think i make
enough money for that
right i don't know these people i'm
getting paid chicken nuggets i don't
know
my wife's an accountant my wife does not
work anymore she takes care of the baby
baby goes to school my wife could do all
that stuff and i trust my wife and then
if she does take the money what am i
going to do and what am i going to do
she raised a child she
sat there
a kid came out of her [ __ ] that trumps
everything she wins yeah she wins i'm
not going to argue
i would love to see you guys as roomies
from the studio apartment real [ __ ]
odd couple yeah that'd be great
oh my god you know to have
to have franco
run your business affairs and pay your
checks and like you know they always
people call me all the time and the
services sound great
i just can't give you my access i hadn't
had a great i don't know a great
commercial agent i've known her since
she was an assistant she was like a
[ __ ] animal in this thing fake tits
she was calling people at midnight with
auditions what is fake ted's outfit oh
she's an animal she's an animal
she would call me at midnight with
auditions this chick and one day she
said [ __ ] this chick
this chick was a hairdresser
that needed money and started being an
assistant an agency
here's what she did she bought an agency
and she's an agent today and i gotta
tell you something she's pretty [ __ ]
good yeah yeah it sounds like she was
doing a great job and that's a savage
but she made one mistake what
paperwork the contract paperwork for you
to sign with they want your bank
information
what for what to pay you is that what
they say right there that's where the
deal ended yeah that's when i ripped
that up and i said take me off your imdb
i haven't given
what if nothing put a stamp on that
[ __ ] and send it [ __ ] via
mail people do it all the time you don't
need my bank account you're giving no
one access but
who doesn't get all your bank
information necessary
no no no that's i'm not saying there's a
system in that level
the reason why i could never have an
assistant
is because i don't know what the next
move is right yes
when i get up in the morning i outline
eight things seven things six things
you know my notebook is to the t you
come to my house right now it's just you
write it all by hand or is it in your
phone
all by
so if you go to my house right now it
says 1 15 to 1 22 to sunday and i have
monday tuesday i have a big calendar it
goes seven minutes at a time no seven
[ __ ] days
i have a i have a notebook okay i have a
schedule i have like a calendar that's a
leather binder
and when you call me and say thursday or
two i write it in there but i don't
worry about that till the week up
all my world is the week of yeah so on
my notebook it says 1 15 or whatever the
[ __ ] and then i put monday tuesday
wednesday thursday friday saturday the
top thing is right two hours
then number two is jiu jitsu at 12
o'clock or drilling at 11 o'clock or
wednesday i have a [ __ ] stupid radio
interview at 11.
my day is on that piece of paper to the
t wow i'll tell you what i'm going to
write i'm going to tell you who i'm
going to meet i'm going to tell you
everything no because that's
what you need to do yeah i want to be
responsible for all my time if you join
weight watchers you know why you lose
weight because at the end of the week
you watch what you [ __ ] ate and when
you see when you see it right now i
don't know nothing all week yeah i swear
to god yeah
chocolate cake chocolate cake you
[ __ ] ate cocktail
so it makes you claim responsibility
yeah that's actually brilliant so if you
see the whole week right now
this is how the life changes when you go
responsible for the minute
i'm responsible for the [ __ ] minute i
want to be i want to tell you where i'm
like i tell my wife i'm walking through
that door at two o'clock on monday and
wednesday i go to jiu jitsu at 11 15. i
warm up at 12 i do the class to one then
i do the [ __ ] mobility class to 145.
i'm interested in my car i get in my car
at 5 2
10 2 and i'm home at [ __ ] 10 after
two you know i'm either home ten minutes
five minutes to the tea and i do the
same process wow i sit down
sweaty and hungry
sweaty and hungry i sit down and i go
right to
bjjournal.com come on and i click the
date and i write the move i learned and
i write down that i got on the mat
and then i checked my emails bjj journal
is a jujitsu thing
i thought it was a porn session no no no
no no no no okay i'm sorry
how bad i did
so i write down the number and then i
from there i check my emails and i make
my calls because if i took an hour
non-business business is first even if
i'm hungry
so after i do all that then i go in the
kitchen and i make a protein drink
i drink that and then my lunch is ready
and i'll run in the shower i'll wash my
[ __ ] with the bacterial soap so i guess
that's right off me i get my hair done
everything and then i come out i eat
lunch it's all a pattern
after lunch i go right back in the
office and i make my calls that's my
call time so if i [ __ ] took time out
of my money which is jiu jitsu yeah i
don't make money by going to jiu jitsu
yeah but i have to work the hour and a
half before jiu jitsu which i do i start
working at 9 30 and i leave at 11
and from two to that's my schedule were
you always that self-disciplined no so
how did you get that way because that's
where that's so hard for because
i do a million different we're in
business for ourselves yeah you are kate
quigley corporation all these idiots i'm
the ceo of you're a ceo sucking my dick
kate giggly is the ceo of kate quigley
international yeah lee syed is the ceo
of of lee scion international and joey
diaz is the ceo of joey diaz
international whether i got a day job
i'm still joey diaz international and
you're still katelyn 100
whatever you do whether you're bobby
sharon whether you're richie mcmanus
whether you're nick smith you're bobby
sharon international
that means you're a bit once you look at
yourself as a [ __ ] business business
you're not [ __ ] around yeah you know
we walk around until we're 28 nothing's
happening i went to law school because
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
mumbling [ __ ] [ __ ]
they didn't teach you and then listen
yeah and that dirty i didn't know this
at 35 i didn't know this and i got to be
honest i don't think i knew this at 40.
huh and one day i'm one of my cocaine
things because i was anal when i did
cocaine i would do math
once
what if i sold 40 kilos at 12 000. i
paid eight thousand wait you're like
thinking of those [ __ ]
you did a calculator i did not calculate
it
you know me old school
but one night i was just thinking about
your time
how we don't
take time to think about our time
you know when i was 25 and married i
didn't think about my time at home
now i think about my time at home you
know yeah when i come to uk in three
years you're gonna hit big kate and
what's gonna happen is this
your comedy's gonna hit your tv career
is gonna hit
but then some [ __ ] stupid agent
he's gonna come up to you and say hey
you should do a really show and you're
like well how many have a cbs show or a
netflix show or uh hbo show i'm going
great with and the other part of my day
is spent on my standard plus i have a
boyfriend i love i have a dog i you know
this takes right you just don't wake up
in the [ __ ] morning you take quickly
you go to ballet you gotta i see what
you go to ballet you do everything you
swim you play tennis i've seen you with
the tennis racket you're showing your
ass bent over
not so much but yeah yeah of course one
thing about you is you're very athletic
you just don't become you know and when
you because you're 32 now okay 34. okay
in six years
you have to work a little longer trust
me
you know
i guess an hour from an hour and a half
to two hours that's 10 hours yeah but
some stupid agents are going to come to
you and say that i've seen a thousand
times in this town
to say hey he just called and they have
a brilliant idea and they're going to
pay you this amount you're going to be
an [ __ ] i'm going to do it and then
i'll become the law diminishing returns
i totally agree now your time
can't
so you're going to slip somewhere you're
really going to bomb in cleveland yeah
and it's gonna and then the word's gonna
get up and she's starting to bomb she's
not focused
and they don't they don't give a [ __ ]
they're getting the commission
once you disappear they'll get some
other hot blonde to come in when she's
18 and you're gone
you control all this
so whether you're a painter an
electrician
because let's say you're a construction
kid and you didn't go to college i'm
sure that you have a dream you want to
be in a band of course that's what keeps
that day job alive is my [ __ ] dream
if you want that dream to happen you got
to document it
all that has to be documented
on how you're going to get a dream yeah
well i'm going to start a band and i'm
going to write three songs
that's not gonna [ __ ] work it's a
short plan that's not gonna work that's
a short-term plan with the end with a
rope with a noose
at the end
oh my god
i started getting it in boulder you know
when
before i got locked up
before i got went to prison i started
swimming in the mornings
at 6 30 and that changed everything
because i was like [ __ ]
this is the first time ever that i have
a day job
and before my day job i put an hour and
a half and a [ __ ] pool yeah and now
you start going wow
this is important you know you start
seeing the things that are important
you start scheduling do you think also
that it's you
i don't know about you but it took me a
long time to find what the thing was
that was so important to me that i
wanted that's the beauty of the journey
yeah and i'm not just going to pop in
your head you're going to have five
[ __ ] mistakes 100 how many career
mistakes how many career changes do we
have
in our lives i think i think it's one
every seven years every seven years oh
wow really yeah but we evolve as
comedians every seven years see when you
first come out here you write jokes when
you get on stage then one day you write
your agent says to you okay you have to
write your own script and you become a
writer the next thing you know lee's
calling you up and going kate i started
the comedy story online can you be a
a [ __ ] flight attendant in my movie
and next thing you know you're working
and now you've become four or five
different things
then you become more popular and
somebody comes to you and says they want
you to write a book
yeah write no [ __ ] book or you could
sit with a writer and give him
information he can write this [ __ ]
about you you read it 10 years later and
go i'm embarrassed to take this hundred
thousand dollars yeah i'd rather [ __ ]
write this thing myself
take [ __ ] eight years and write what
the [ __ ] i wanted to be in there and i
wanted to see so to do all that you need
time yeah
you know it's time right so time
management it's time
people go in the business for themselves
the reason why they fail is time
management lee will tell you lee knows
so i'm not doing my time but the first
thing when time management when you're
in self business is to take care of
yourself because i think that shoots
chemicals often it does a hundred
percent that's why i totally drop her
off in the morning at 8 30 or 7 or
whatever time she gets on the [ __ ]
train get in the [ __ ] car and take
her because that gets you out i don't
care you brush your teeth it doesn't
matter you're not going nowhere take it
take it to the bus take it to the bus
because once you're out of the house
then it wakes you up and that's when
your creativity starts coming out and
right from there you take two hits off
that joint and you go to the park in
noho and you bring two kettlebells out
and you're out of your [ __ ] apartment
you're outside breathing and that's when
you're crazy
once you get out of that [ __ ] house
that what what happens to you the
earlier you get out of the [ __ ] house
what happens here is a [ __ ] miracle
and not once you do it once
like once you do it on a monday and then
you do it on thursday one week then you
do it on monday then you do it on
wednesday and thursday it changes yeah
and once you do it four times in one
week you're like oh i may be uh now i'm
not telling you to get up and do
anything yeah just get out of the house
just wake up then in time you start
doing things and that time those four
hours
you'd be amazed that's why the what was
the army slug and we do more by nine
o'clock than you do within the whole
[ __ ] day it's
that's actually amazing that's such good
insight because anytime i get up and do
anything even just you know what i walk
every day to 7 11 and get a cup of
coffee in the morning and i know i'm
wasting money and people are like you
shouldn't buy because i just want to get
outside
if you start your job
yeah right it's such a gift and when
you're outside you look at the sun
and you look at people and you go wow
look at all these people in traffic
killing themselves to get to work look
at how lucky the opportunity i have
so i don't have to do this guess what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna go upstairs and
tear up that [ __ ] phone today
well i'm gonna tear up some [ __ ]
jokes today i'm gonna go to a coffee
shop and you know what i'm gonna do an
owl kettlebell workout and do push-ups
and sit-ups that's the best advice i
jumped some rope i didn't know this
yeah all those years i was spinning my
[ __ ] wheels
until i stopped doing blow i was
spinning but even before before i
stopped doing blow those two years
i was already it was like i was
preparing to get off the blower i was
organizing my time i started not hanging
out with people as comedians yeah we
think it's cool to wake up in the
morning right from there and then
let's call our 60 million but we're
going to dodge again
let's get together and talk about how
bad life is out here that's all you're
basically doing i can't handle you're
getting together with six comics to eat
chinese food
to hear a group grow so by the time you
get home at 3 30 you want to shoot
yourself because if you're doing movies
or you're doing well
they make you feel [ __ ] bad exactly
and if you're not you feel bad just
being around them
one day i came home and i said i'm
cutting off the comedy [ __ ] uh group
group in the afternoon yeah and that
changed my [ __ ] life completely i
just try to be around positive comedy
group group yeah the comedy group group
six guys and a girl and it's like
[ __ ] friends and you got five losers
and i'm one of them talking about i'm
not getting spots here
i didn't go here with rogan i didn't do
this for what it's all just a waste of
time that you could be spending on
projecting where you are going that's
why you got to be responsible for every
total minute man
and just write the time down
even if you do it an hour later you keep
writing that time down when you want to
do it eventually
you'll do it at that time you're so
right if you keep writing it down
i'm gonna [ __ ] jump off the roof 9
a.m jump off a roof
and every day you jump at 9 20 9 35 9 18
9 11. and before you know it you keep
right nine o'clock i'm jumping off the
roof
you will jump off the roof every [ __ ]
day at 9 00 am it's so
the power of the pen amazing has changed
my [ __ ] life man
it's changed my life i still have to
write i still have to write something to
memorize it if i'm trying to learn a
script if i or even new material even if
it's because i really write on stage a
lot so i'll try things but if it works i
always you know have my set recorded i
have to write it for it to really be
sunk in i think there's something
between your hand and your mind or
something to me even like text messages
i don't like text messages i know you
know it's so funny yeah i tell you why i
don't like it because
i'm so old school with that [ __ ] pen
yeah people knew how strong the pen was
they wouldn't
you're the only person i know
who i always call first and don't text
you're literally the only person because
you don't one or two times i texted you
first and you never answered and then
you'd just call me i was like all right
this dude doesn't text me it's so funny
how many people text me i just erased it
especially business related texts you're
never going to get a hold of me but it's
so great because every time i call you
even if it's just to ask you a quick
question i feel like we have a moment
oh yeah yeah no no i want to hear
people's voices man yeah i'm old school
i'm gonna hear your [ __ ] voice i
wanna make sure everything's straight i
don't wanna text with nobody i don't
wanna text fight either nothing makes me
crazier than a text fight and like i
feel like a lot of guys because guys
don't like uh to argue of course but i
feel like a lot of guys are a little
passive they try to avoid the argument
so they do the text the text fighting i
can't stand it i mean can we just get on
the phone for one minute and have like
face or person to person contact even
over the phone it can clarify things
that don't even need to be a problem
it's so funny how you don't want to be
that person
when things started changing i was like
okay this is cool but
something ain't right and then one day a
commercial came on for like
some airline company when the guy comes
in and everybody's sitting there all
like
waiting to hear what the boss says and
he goes things are changing again
our sales are down everybody starts
giving out plane tickets to people and
he goes we've gotten too comfortable
with the [ __ ] emails and this we're
going back on the field old school and i
knew that there was still people left
like me you know tommy easter was
driving back from georgia
and i called him like oh tommy what are
you gonna do he goes well i'm gonna drop
my hand i'm gonna drive but i go tommy
before you get in the car
go online and make a list of all the
comedy clubs in that right
why are you dead heading back i go
number one you got no reason to come
back in time there's nothing going on in
the open mic community
i go if i was you i just [ __ ] stop at
every club my name is tom east
i like to do a showcase and i go why not
it's an education
that'd be so fun doing showcases you
know the big mitch hedberg story was he
got in a van with chart hogan and a
volkswagen where they had and they went
across the country one year's feature
acts yeah and they did 50 guest sets and
20 clubs hire them you want to get hired
you want to get hired as a free trade
yeah get in the car and drive across the
country and do five-minute guests and
say i'll do anything
yeah for sure and they'll feature you
don't have to live in l.a you have to
see nobody else see rogue you have to
see [ __ ] local features
yeah i did it all the [ __ ] time yeah
i remember [ __ ] still this is one of
the it's and you don't get mad at it now
like now it's like stripe these are
comedy stripes this is why
people pay you these are the reasons why
people pay you well i would think it'd
be rude wouldn't like if like let's say
you give someone a guess set right and
then they go up they went to the manager
like hey i want to feature here at some
point doesn't that put you off no no
let's talk about this okay so
i was living in boulder i had maybe 20
minutes
and my good friend called me he goes uh
club in minneapolis
arizona and somewhere else
is looking for mc's i said okay i got a
car and i drove 16 hours and i got on
stage on friday and the guy liked me and
he put me back on stage saturday they
gave me three weeks
three weeks later i got to call the
clubs about the business
okay first of all lee you're not going
to go into improv
okay right now type in
comedy clubs in indiana
i love you guys
why
i just do all right we got crackers okay
we got mortys okay we got comedy sports
okay
uh
let's go indianapolis or indiana i said
indiana indiana here's the top five
according to tripadvisor
mortys crackers comedy sports the comedy
attic in bloomington
and snickers comedy club in fort wayne
okay so
comedy sports is an improv troupe so
erase that [ __ ] okay sorry so you got
mortys you got crackers you got the
other two okay none of them is an improv
okay so morty's brings in top headliners
and sodas crackers but every once in a
while they got filler those guys got no
[ __ ] say yeah if you you know the the
regular local headliners i got no say
yeah if you walk in there when one of
those guys is on stage and ask and give
them a good reference say i work at the
comedy store i work at the improv
they'll put you up for five [ __ ]
minutes the last two what are they uh
the comedy attic i've heard of that one
in blue both of those [ __ ] will
put you out and then the snickers comedy
club right is apparently the number one
nightlife in fort wayne right they'll
put you up too if you go in there
because it's like a michigan headliner
yeah they have those clubs everywhere
they have michigan they have them and
whatever you have to know which ones to
go to them
see if you walk into one where the
manager's running the thing and the book
is not there they're gonna give you a
number so you avoid those [ __ ]
that's a worse time my friend and i did
this in singapore we were in singapore
uh on a military tour and we were bored
one night we had a night off and we were
like let's just try to find the comedy
clubs and see if they'll throw you up so
apparently it's international because we
went in and they were like so excited to
have american comics and they just threw
us both
yes you could try it overseas that's
what i'm saying now let me ask you this
when you went there was it just people
from singapore were there english guys
there it was mostly people that lived in
singapore but they were super american i
didn't realize english is their first
language in singapore
so they were really americanized they
got all the same jokes but yeah it was
mostly locals it was really cool it was
really
it was so surreal because we weren't
supposed to be in singapore we were
supposed to be there for like one night
and then leave and like a light bulb
broke on the helicopter we were supposed
to take to wherever we were going next
and so we couldn't take the chopper out
so we got stuck there so we ended up
getting to perform there which was like
so [ __ ] cool yeah yeah it was so
shout out to the uh the bad chopper
mechanic who couldn't let us that's
my [ __ ] craziness ends international
stuff
what do you mean you won't do it
petrifies me to death why you mean to
just have like this everything or to get
there specifically like the travel i
tried
i tried jamaica twice
and i tried
puerto rico i could go there what's
wrong with with why what happened in
jamaica it just creeped me the [ __ ] out
the island dripped you out everything
everything the food were you there for
vacation or for work one time on
vacation one day to shoot a movie the
rest of the world is in jamaica though
there's like other parts yeah but how
can jamaica be bad isn't it like it's
like
i saw the chickens and [ __ ]
the chicken tape weird the food tastes
the way that the jamaican jerk chicken
i don't like those i've never heard that
before i went to jamaica and it turned
me to like all international travel
you're like i'm never going anywhere
because of my felonies and everything
i'm so scared to go internationally they
lock me abroad and [ __ ] so i just leave
it alone i'm pretty like i don't have a
passport but in many ways i don't want
one
like when they told me you couldn't have
a password i'm like fine i ain't going
to [ __ ] do it it's not like i'm going
to ireland i'm not going to love you
fellaini you still if you have a felony
on your record is that there forever
oh it's like herpes unless i get rid of
it i know i thought maybe like it goes
away for good service like you know
after somebody who found these in
colorado and like two in seattle what
are they
the ones in colorado a second degree
burglary an accessory to a felony the
one in seattle is like
uh something to domestic violence which
i didn't smack no no woman i believe
that when you let's say you and lee live
together okay
so how was your great job obviously
was your ex boyfriend yeah and i saw you
out in the bar and we got into a fight
it'd be domestic violence
that's right if i'm out with lee oh and
i run into you at a bar and we get in a
fight i think if he lives with you oh
because you're my expert yeah that's
what happened oh
so no no it was a horror show but still
that domestic violence thing about them
for a long time and then there was like
a simple assault charge at a bar i got
busted uh the comedy underground in
seattle like if you walk into the comedy
if you call ron reed at the comedy on
the ground and i'm coming through can i
do a guess that you got to guess that
a manager a comics comic type deal lee
you're looking backwards oh i'm going
through changes right now this is
changes i'm enjoying hearing all the
felonies this is fascinating
to me yeah this is deep wait the second
one the second one you said you were uh
uh you were what is it called when you
help someone else with a their accessory
yeah you were an accessory what were you
an accessory too kidnapping what
kidnapping how were you an accessory to
kidnap this was all the same uh crime
the whole kidnapping thing with ken
bella
i my attorney plea bargained down the
second degree burglary an accessory to a
family
now the accessory to a felony i think
you're one of the first people to find
this out on mushrooms listen to me the
accessory to a felony is very
interesting
because that's what [ __ ] that's how he
[ __ ] them
because the court everybody said
accessory to what felony
the second degree burglary or the
kidnapping
and he would say the second-degree
burglary and it's non-violent
because his job was to get it now it's a
long function wait so were you convicted
though oh yeah i got locked up and
everything oh but he had a great case
you did a great you did a great job i
was looking at kidnapping
i'm looking at i'm looking at kidnapping
one and two if i take it to trial and i
lose it's 48 years times two
i never see daylight the first offer was
12 or 14. then they went to nine for
kidnapping and i was like
nine for kidnapping means i'd do nine
are you terrified
i would be not terrified because i
thought i thought at that time
like i thought at that time i'd split
let's do something as it got closer i
was out on bail
so i at least think you got on bail you
could [ __ ] think and deal with the
world would you split you're just gonna
like hike into mexico i didn't know what
i was gonna do i had a friend
i had a friend that had a hertz
dealership in honduras
and there's no extradition treaties with
honduras this is i had friends that were
just trying to help me out oh my god the
more i thought about it i'm like you
have to run with this the rest of your
life
you know one day you come back to the
states you have a wife a kid a family
you get into a car accident take it to
the hospital you'll want it for [ __ ]
two thousand years yeah you can do that
that was your whole life so forget about
that [ __ ]
but then this attorney just worked
miracles and i talked it out and i said
you know what i did it i always knew i
was going to go due time
i knew i knew i knew it was in my cards
i knew i was going to get it i might as
well do this and get it over
and that was it
wow
what was it like
i'm so i don't know why i'm fascinated
by like what really goes on in prison
because you see movie and you know
movies and tv but i don't that's
probably not real like what does it
really mean
nothing
on the outside nothing i i knew i was
going to get in this
all i could wish for was every day that
i you know there was crazy people in
there even when i got to the camp
there were people that had been there
for murder man you know they still have
those tendencies and now
there's a thin line for respecters and
the outside and what respect is inside
with people yeah there's a weird uh
thing in your mind
you know there's a lot so i just kept to
myself you know i had a friend
that had gotten into trouble and i took
him out to lunch a bunch of times
and he hooked me up he called the prison
and talked to the one guard he goes is
my buddy
he was well
he was rich this guy his name is ed
kabash he was a bad [ __ ] he was
a geek that became a
a drug millionaire
he started hanging out with this chick
we knew about drugs maybe he made money
and then wow he crashed two cars in one
week
he had a liquor store
oh yeah he had two chicks he was right
they were driving porsches i mean this
guy was banging no that sounds nice but
when he got locked up he paid a lot of
money
to get taken care of
he paid a lot of money you can really
pay people
how interesting did you pay money to get
taken care of a little bit really like a
couple people just like when i got in
they told me what to do and i thought i
took care of you you seemed like a guy
that would very quickly move up though
and be running your own little ring no i
didn't i tried to keep because you don't
want to step on nobody's toes right when
i got to my final destination yeah i was
having a great [ __ ] time really yeah
you're having fun yeah
you're the first you're the first person
i've ever seen they were having fun in
jail i mean you can look at two [ __ ]
ways you could look at it from two
[ __ ] ways i had no re you know i was
working in a kitchen i had access to
food yep yeah which meant
people wanted to talk to me because i
had access to food oh yeah of course
to make nachos they wanted this
they like skimmed milk you know you're
winking at me on purpose are you hot
okay it's just like going like you know
oh my god this coat is all this food so
you get favors you're fine got it okay
you got your favorites yeah you know
like yeah the guys that work in the
garbage crew
yeah my girlfriend's gonna drop off a
pair of panties or the exit over here
that's the kind of favors yeah oh i
think
no no like maybe uh listen you like to
do coke how about i give you an eight
ball okay
got it
go to this spot there's a bag there's
gonna be coconut put it down and dirty
panties they don't they don't search you
you know on the way back or something
just think once you have those type of
jobs people so like i had friends that
would come to me and go my wife brought
me to molly's bro can you put them in
the freezer for me i could be two right
off the top
bam oh my god like that add access to a
freezer the hookup had access to a
property
of 60 yards from the main facility so
the guys that were selling steroids and
[ __ ] would say to me you have a stash
over there we'll pay you some money you
know
we got some heroin
so i would put it somewhere where i
couldn't get in trouble for it what i
would put it somewhere where it's not in
my car but i'm watching it but not
really
so if there was crates outside and the
garbage man had to pick them up i would
stash the heroin under a crate or
something so nobody got in trouble oh my
god i could always be the garbage man
there's always so risky there's always a
doubt you were involved in dangerous
activity you could have been taken out
no i was on the
[Music]
no i wasn't i was fine
it wasn't like that at all they were
like low-level dudes but but heroin is a
high-level drug it was there was a guy
that was a biker that i became friends
with but i still think about him he's a
solid [ __ ] white dude
solid white dude just a [ __ ] banger i
would think about i still think about
him late at night and uh he used to get
meth every monday
from his girlfriend his girlfriend would
come in and swap spit with him with a
condiment and fill it up with [ __ ]
meth
like two eight balls and like a little
condom every monday every monday oh wow
and he would put it over here in his
mouth and walk in with him
they would search him and [ __ ] he'd
come in and then he'd call me over to
his room and we'd do a little line of
met
and then we'd go play basketball in the
gym and i thought i was [ __ ] julia
serving my heart was gonna blow up
you know i still think of those guys
toray pyles the black dude that was a
high-level [ __ ]
he had seven [ __ ] girlfriends and
each of them had a different [ __ ]
porsche
mercedes it was amazing on the outside
on the outside seven girlfriends but how
long was he three kids he was living
there for 12 or 13 years he was what but
he got paying for seven girls he got oh
this [ __ ] was making cash in
there that's crazy this is when the
crips were going from california to
colorado and distributing cocaine what
do you need seven girlfriends for in
jail though because he was big dick
pimping do they have conjugal visits at
this gym oh oh
oh i heard that so he worked with me in
the kitchen
so me and him what you do is if you have
a visit on saturday and sunday you got
to sit next to animals
if i have a visit next to animals so if
i take a job monday through friday yeah
my visit to saturday and sunday it's
tough for me to finger you when there's
200 animals in the room but if i take a
visit with you on wednesday
there's nobody in the back there's four
people there i'll just tell you come in
bring a basket you're not serious yes
you're all in the same room no no no no
so when when you visit somebody on
[ __ ] saturday and sunday
it's a big room and you just get on the
table and you talk so it's pretty rough
for me to finger you uh because there's
200 people so what he's saying is
there's no one
monday through friday if you work in the
kitchen you get visits
so you would say come in monday and
tuesday bring a basket of food we'll
have lunch
wear a dress with no panties
and we would sit by the i would make you
sit by the
door there was a door here and there was
a window so i would make you pop up so
you could see around and i would eat
your [ __ ] while you were looking at the
guards and see if any of the guards were
coming in oh yeah there was a scam
though there weren't really conjugal
visits but there were conjurings oh yeah
i would give you a stabbing every monday
if you came to visit me the girlfriend
at the time i was given a monday
stabbings their secret conjugal position
happening in jail show up on mondays
until they're not conjugal
i got it
monday and tuesdays they would come in
and you sit down like nothing's
happening yeah you bring a dress yeah
and we look around the guards leaving
pop up that dress i give you a little
stab a little sucky sucky and then we
talk for two hours like nothing happens
you were hooked up yeah we eat chinese
food you could bring food in and then
bring me groceries for the week they
check the groceries and take a vigo off
the top
but then at least they take care of you
you know what i'm saying kate have you
ever loved anyone enough to stay with
them through prison
and then not only love them enough to
stay with
imagine if you were with a really great
guy you know and then he did go to jail
for you for something he did that was
like heroic you know like he saved
another girl but he accidentally kind of
killed a guy because he lost his temper
whatever and then he goes to jail and
he's amazing and there's a way that you
can sneak in and have this like fake in
the kitchen like he pays off the guards
sex every once in a while but not have
to deal with all the relationship drama
at home that'd be like a perfect
scenario yeah you have this mapped out
wait what do you think these chicks
become i have one i am on
meetupprisoner.com why do you think
these chicks get together with these
[ __ ] killers and [ __ ]
just to think i got a dick in me the guy
killed 18 people no that's kind of gonna
rub it off yeah yeah i'm saying i'm
dating the guy
18 people
my guy went to jail for heroic reasons
yeah yeah sure yeah you gotta hook up
with a guy that's a hero good luck
well you know a hero with a violent
temper huh i'm kidding there's no such
thing as a hero with the bible
[ __ ] hero
you lost your [ __ ] mind okay
he killed 18 people you have to get them
we don't want to i don't want to we just
we can't help it there's something about
a guy that will kill people that's like
you know it's it's primal it's like the
man you know it's like the beast inside
we don't really want him to we don't
really want murderers you know it was
funny because the guy that gave us the
guy that gave me the tv called me the
other day from the halfway house he
didn't call me from the halfway house
he had an hour to look for a job and we
were talking
and he was telling me that you know he
hasn't had a he's seen his wife
and the whole thing but he's still
nothing's gone down but he goes
there's some [ __ ] hot chicks at the
halfway house and i'm like i know
like i'm sick at the halfway house
sounds like a great reality show i got
off the phone and i got off the phone
and i was i don't know where i think it
was in my office and i was trying to
write jokes or something at night or
organize something and i started
thinking about the conversation we had
and when i was in the halfway house the
top two floors were for men
but the bottom floor were for girls
there was only uh maybe 10 girls there
was two rooms for girls the bottom floor
was a kitchen like a kitchen where you
went and they gave your groceries for
the week yeah and then there was like a
microwave and then there was like a
bathroom then there was a conference
room and then there was the hallway
so when i was in doing time there was a
guy in there used to tell me about his
girlfriend
and he would tell me you're on your way
to bctc she's going to be in bctc
i still remember her name and everything
i don't want to even mention it oh my
god and i didn't think nothing i'm a guy
i i was i you know
and finally i go to bct say i walk in
and after two days who do i meet i meet
the girl and i said hey i met your boy
yeah he said you're coming here we
became friends and
i never thought nothing of it and after
a couple weeks i started selling coke in
the halfway house
one thing led to another right exactly
one thing led to another i had to find
employment in that one led to another
one friday i come in from selling cars
you're lazy and i pull up and the index
knew i would come in i was loaning out
money and i come and i sign up
but in those days if somebody calls for
you or somebody wants to talk to you
they leave a message in your book
so when you walk in they give you your
book and you sign in what time you come
in this like let's say they want to give
you ua yeah let's say they want you to
pee there'll be a note in there for a ui
well
there'll be a no you have to sign it you
got two hours to piss from the time you
signed that piece of paper if your
attorney called it was in there but this
one that i get in the open thing and
there's a note from
this girl and she goes when you come in
can you please stop you see okay
and i make that i didn't expect nothing
of it i thought that she wanted to buy
blow that's right
i walk in there's nobody in the hallway
i get to her door i knock on the door
she opens the door in [ __ ] victoria's
secret i don't know what to do but i'm
going to invic i grab her tits we
started making out
i take my dick out the whole thing she
says we can't do it in here i [ __ ]
took her out of there and took her into
that little kitchen area oh my god bent
her over no condom no nothing i ate her
ass ate a [ __ ] and just dip that
monster in there that sounds like a
porno yeah yeah yeah
and then after that it was like every
time i saw it i gave her a stab
so we used to go to therapy we used to
go to therapy together like the whole
you know you have to go to group ropes
so there was some group groups
this really is a partnership we were
producing there were some group groups
that were at the halfway house but some
group grocer at a place called serenity
right now that's what you called it
group growth
so we you have to go to like two days a
week you have to go to these meetings
right it got to the point where her and
i would go to the same meetings and it
was three hour meetings but they haven't
at the hour and a half mark you'd have a
break
and i just give her a look and we'd go
behind the car in the parking lot i eat
her ass suck a [ __ ] and give her a
stabbing and i'd walk back in like
nothing happened that was a [ __ ]
night sounds like great therapy a year
later even after she had a boyfriend one
day i was riding my bike and i saw her
walking her dog what's going on she was
like nothing she was like moving down to
the guy i'm in love oh come on she goes
yeah what does he do for a living
because he's like a salesman he travels
like let's go over and smoke a joint no
i was over there three minutes eating a
monkey oh my god it was terrible yeah
yeah wow i met someone there sometimes
you have people like that that then i
met a [ __ ] girl at the halfway house
that i still remember how beautiful she
was her girl her daughter no no
that was so [ __ ] hot a brunette
and she was in that because she she was
a manager of macy's like a purse chick
and she stole like 9 000 purses and they
[ __ ] put her in a federal macy's
whatever the [ __ ] stealing from the
dollar store one of those [ __ ] first
places she was a big time chick the
purse is like 400 bucks in 1987.
she was very decent
like she was very you know those chicks
are like i would never eat on that you
know like one of those chicks oh okay
and i became friends with her you know
i'm gonna make jokes out of it i would
always make jokes out like stupid jokes
like how was your you know like she
didn't know i was goofing on her right
but i would say how was your day
the place is just disgusting i've never
lived in such a place and i would just
laugh
yeah did you find the fleas yet are
there fleas here i have to call my
attorney
so i became i became friends with her
she was really pretty really pretty
banging body she was thick
she had short brown hair
and one and i'd see him walking and one
day i was dry because i had privileges
to drive so one day i pulled over you
want to ride she's going to get me right
to the mall she was working at the ball
i took it to the mall boom dropped her
off nothing happened good to see you see
you tonight
see your therapy that type of [ __ ] how
did you earn privileges to drive at the
halfway house what did you have you have
to get a job and stay on the job and pay
rent on time and how much does it cost
to live there seventy-five dollars a
week can you move in
you're not going to criminal okay so
this guy was really sweet this would be
good for me this girl was really sweet
kate and i'm sure you know which i asked
them once i don't have a boyfriend she
goes god forbid
i dated a guy for two years and when i
got locked up he stopped writing me you
know all this [ __ ]
she was kind of like a pretty girl
always wore [ __ ] badass clothes like
her job was pretty badass yeah
and one day i saw walking and i picked
her up and i had this gym
i had this little gym with a punching
bag a radio a joint a jump rope some
gloves and weights
i rented the gym for 35 dollars a month
i had that gym since jesus unless
chicago was going away it was a garage
right sounds cool like three blocks away
from the halfway house i didn't know
i was gonna end up in the halfway house
when i rented the garage it just worked
out that way
so i pick her up and we're talking like
are you gonna go to work she goes no i'm
just bored in the halfway house
and i said something to her like
something off call like i gotta tell you
something
why don't the [ __ ] you have a boyfriend
what the [ __ ] is going on with you nice
and she said something like
something like well why won't you date
me dog i didn't even say a word i made a
[ __ ] u-turn
and i'll never forget she had on heels
like she was dressed like an attorney
with like a
little dress over her knees and [ __ ]
she's badass with stockings with black
stockings i was running [ __ ] tear
this yeah
and she's like where are we going i got
to make a stop i pulled into that garage
like [ __ ]
like i'm sure like the dude in the
garage like the dude sounds awesome
she's so lucky
i took her to a garage she took her back
to the garage it was so funny because
maybe i got the best garage what are we
gonna do in here
she was tremendous she was beautiful my
hair was short we started making it i
took a little vest off a little penguin
suit i took that skirt off i threw on
the [ __ ] bench
she thought her head was going to blow
up like nobody had ever treated her that
way just like when you said a weight
bench it was a weight belt
bench like nobody had to put this girl
in the back wow she looked at the bench
she was like really i go get on that
[ __ ] bed i picked the [ __ ] legs up
i ate that muffler i ate that monkey i
[ __ ] condom i went in there like a
soldier jesus and that was the end of
that dog and it was tremendous she was
beautiful
and when i was driving home i don't know
if she was crying i don't know what the
[ __ ] the problem was she was
why would she eat me i'm just kidding
you made her see god
she was like i'm scared
oh my god we were friends after that for
a while i mean we never had sex that
time but we were friends for a while we
talked each time even after i got out of
the halfway house you were calling me
with dilemmas you know she was one
dilemma i wonder if maybe the mushrooms
are making me a little more bashful
because when you're telling these super
dirty sex stories i'm getting a little
like no you've all lived these stories
you've been [ __ ] up
how many times you get [ __ ] on a
weightlifting bench on a weight lifting
bench not one time
what kind of animal are you
how many times have you gotten banged at
the gym in the men's bathroom tell me
the truth never come on i swear to god
the woman's bathroom nobody said to you
give me that sweaty i never [ __ ] a
stranger at the gym and never [ __ ] a
guy
don't you have any [ __ ] adventures
yeah i mean fitting rooms like at the
mall like movie theater bathrooms i just
haven't got a boyfriend or just a random
[ __ ] oh the movie no i don't
really [ __ ] randoms i really don't see
the boyfriends that took you to the
movie theater and said take it off your
dirty animal oh well not necessarily a
boyfriend just like someone i'm dating
so i would take it to the movie theater
put a hole in the popcorn put my dick in
the box
and put popcorn over so you grab the
popcorn you massage the helmet and [ __ ]
that's great joey that's great
invisible assault you're hydrated
that's if i was in the sixth grade he's
a joke yeah sure
he's a joke you're the only one with
jokes [ __ ] oh that's so funny
i don't know man i've been having i've
been trying to have more adventures i'm
trying to learn to be um i'm trying to
learn to be able to be more casual about
it and like but i don't [ __ ] strangers
no like i never meet a guy and within
like an hour we're [ __ ] i never do
that two hours
three three but only once
only once i i just don't do it i don't
know why let's say you know listen man
when you go to a bar it's such a cheesy
[ __ ] environment
but like
one time i met a girl at midnight i was
in boulder walking around and she was
walking around she asked me if i had a
light we started talking we started
walking by three o'clock we were naked
and and at the university behind them
oh yeah we just kept walking and talking
you know sometimes you get attracted to
somebody and [ __ ] happens man i mean
i've
there have been nights that i would have
done it that i can think of in my head
where the actually this is interesting
the guys that there were two guys that i
wanted to hook up with so bad within
like two three hours of meeting him and
we were one in particular oh god he's so
uh you just play nfl football body of
like a greek [ __ ] like god so we're
in an uber i just met him we start
hooking up it's i can tell it's gonna be
amazing and i would have gone home with
him and then all of a sudden he was like
you know we should do this next time
and i was like are you sure and he's
like yeah
we should do this next time so now i
wonder if maybe like he had a girlfriend
there or something like every once in a
while a guy will
will push me off and they're usually the
ones i want the most it happened with
him he said we should do this next time
and then there was
one other time i tried oh i was so into
this guy we started making out this bar
we just met he was super funny he kind
of had the edge like he might punch
somebody or beat somebody up in the bar
which i like you know i like that so we
started hooking up at the bar
and then
he's like he calls an uber and then i
think we're gonna get in it and go back
to his place together and then he was
like hey it was so good to meet you i'll
definitely hit you up we'll do this next
time and never heard from him again
and i thought the sex with that one was
going to be like
off the charts hot so what do you think
that is because those guys were the ones
i wanted the most ever
it means i want guys
that are unavailable
on some deep level
that's why the ones i instantly want to
bang because my whole vagina knows my
wish i don't know what are they telling
me this [ __ ] call the psychiatrist and
tell them that therapy is working
my vagina's psychic no uh
it's [ __ ] crazy man
it takes a lot to catch yourself
yeah i'm saying like it takes a lot to
go you know what
this ain't gonna work tonight it's not
something that i've always ever said
because look at me i gotta take what
they've given you know saying i can't
say well this ain't gonna work tonight
i'll see you next time kate
yeah what is that who the hell knows
kate maybe they are married maybe
it's gotta be me i gotta be attracted
to people that like
can't because they have a reason like a
person or or an emotional block
like wait or their dick just doesn't
work
i'm attracted to guys who are impotent
are you really i don't know but it's
that's what i'm saying why else would
they be turning me down
are you a tight guy's home and they got
dead nick a lot no it's only happened
once well they were doing drugs yeah
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] i don't really
take guys home though i if i'm gonna go
i go to their place i don't take my
place why not because i don't want to
have to kick them out because i don't
like to be rude
and i like to be in charge of when i
leave so if i want to stay i'll stay but
if i want to leave i want to be able to
leave but
if we're at my place then you know i
can't just walk out at any time right so
i have to really trust someone to bring
them home and you're like the party's
over yeah it was good last night when it
lasted i took a look at you this morning
i smelled your feet there's no more i
don't know because sometimes what if you
get them back there and you start
hooking up and there's some surprise you
don't know about like they're really
smelly or
maybe once they get behind closed doors
they act crazy and you don't want them
you know in your apartment but now
they're in your apartment
stop being a young girl man so i'd
rather go to their place and get
murdered there
i'm just kidding it's tough being a
young woman man it really is
not it's [ __ ]
it's gonna be pretty not not to be
pretty
to be fat not to be fat
to you don't know why a guy likes you
you know
there was a girl in high school i had a
glass eye i always think about it
because i think about it most men do you
know because no because when we were in
high school nobody would talk to her oh
because she had a glass of water when
you're young like that you don't think
about
you know people's feelings and i always
think about what
what happened to whether she ever hook
up with somebody that somebody
overlooked the eye
maybe she's missing an eye but she sucks
a good dick so you just say [ __ ] it i'll
take the one with the michael bisping
eye oh
that's what she has so many things i
want to say
she got a little michael
[Music]
you know i mean she didn't she would
never date me even with the one [ __ ]
eyes not like you know you know i'm
saying like she would never [ __ ] date
me i'm just saying that she was very
sweet and i always thought about if
anybody overlooked that
she told me once that she had a crush on
a guy and i knew the guy
and i knew she couldn't get the [ __ ]
guy
i never really said nothing to her was
out of place for me to say something
but from time i always think she was a
nice girl if somebody ever dated her she
had the glass eye that's it
that's sweet yeah there's nothing funny
about it i wonder what what made you
think of her i'm like the girl with the
glass eye who you yeah no
you have no glass eye my personality is
the glass yeah sure right
it's not on the outside it's on the
inside so what else do you have beside
tempe after 10p you have a lot of work
yeah i'm actually uh oh god i gotta
think i'm doing
phoenix actually i'm doing phoenix again
uh
at another club i don't really want to
promote it on here since we're coming
i'm doing uh vegas oh i think i'm doing
vegas end of the month again with steve
byrne and then um
i don't know follow me on twitter i post
everything there i can't think of it off
top of my head joey gave me too many
mushrooms you have a webpage yeah
katequigly.com or instagram and twitter
at kateq funny i'm way better updating
also my facebook fan page that's way
more up to date all the time but um
oh yeah i'm doing a week in vegas with
theo vaughn actually at the lab factory
that's gonna be really fun so
i'm always getting around i'm trying i'm
trying what about the playboy show when
does that go back into season three oh
we should start shooting in the next
eight weeks and then uh what else oh and
check out my podcast you guys listeners
have been listening to my podcast which
is awesome which is called date fails
and i have tony baker doing it with me
now do you know i don't know if you know
tony he's super duper funny black dude
yeah yeah i love that
i know
he's so funny and he's the perfect edge
like the opposite edge of me because
he's got his pulse on like not just
dudes but like these hip like what's
going on with like the hip kids and i
feel like i just know what's going on
with like girls that are crazy so
it's it's cool and we talk about um all
our bad dates and
i'll have you on it sometime
bad dates yeah
i don't have bad dates i just got crabs
i didn't get bad dates i just got crabs
lost
juice and i got a new grill did you see
my i saw your [ __ ] grill
i also want to thank uh
john petrovsky he gave me a [ __ ]
tremendous album he gave me the black
crows
the second album the remedy on it
[ __ ] tremendous i had that on
cassette
and my [ __ ] uh whatever
like i said this weekend myself and kate
will be at tempe and then february third
through the uh the second through the
fourth oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
nashville
coming at you [ __ ] so
take that and put it in your pipe listen
i want to talk to you about something
valentine's day is coming
everybody's always complaining about
being single we don't know what to do or
nothing like that you know it's funny
how my mom used to dress me in suits and
she always liked when i was clean i
won't put a suit on for dick now it's
pretty sad because i'm 54 years old
and i should be wearing suits on stage
and being a little bit more professional
i'ma tell you something what i'm gonna
do out of respect for you guys is get
myself a little indochino suit i went
down there and got measured i went down
to beverly hills and got measured the
whole thing i never went and picked up
the suit because i'm such an [ __ ] i
never go to that part of town but i tell
you what you don't know what it's like
to get measured for a suit compared to a
generic off the [ __ ] rack suit all
right when you go to indochino man
the [ __ ] things they measure are
unbelievable and i'll tell you what like
i'm telling you i know for a fact i'm no
[ __ ] mel gibson but with a suit i
could sell you whatever the hell i need
to sell you tell em when i put on this
suit i'm a savage and [ __ ] indochino is
one of the largest made to measure
menswear brands
you get quality suits made to your exact
measurements for listen to me a perfect
fit you also get to customize your suit
just the way you want it the inside the
outside here's how it works you visit a
showroom or you shop online at
indochino.com
you pick from hundreds of fabrics you
choose your customizations from lapels
to pleats to jacket linings to more you
submit your body measurements you place
your order and wait for the rot for it
to arrive in four weeks that's how easy
it is i'll tell you what i'm gonna do
valentine's day is coming you don't want
to show up with that [ __ ] up sweater
and those disgusting jeans and then
wonder why you're [ __ ] single all
right so this week's listeners you're
gonna any premium indochino suit for
399 dollars unless no i am i'm gonna
tell you what i'm gonna do
my listeners you're gonna get any
premium indochino suit for 389 dollars
at indochino.com
when you enter church at the checkout
that's 50 off the regular price for made
to measure premium [ __ ] suits banging
plus the shipping is free that's
indochino.com
promo code
c-h-u-r-c-h for any premium suit for 389
bucks and free shipping [ __ ] where you
gonna get that action from it's an
incredible deal for a suit and it'll fit
you better than anything you've ever
[ __ ] worn off the rack at kmart
whoever the hell you shop go to
indochino.com right now and press in
church
and get any premium industry no
no chino suit for 389
and shipping is for free that's 50 off
all right go to indochino.com right now
number two
why are you walking around with a stinky
ass again
you wonder why nobody wants to suck your
dick because your ball sack smells your
helmet smells like [ __ ] piss what do
you think happens to your dick in your
[ __ ] when you're 25 years old it's 25
years of getting [ __ ] in the ass with
[ __ ] every day what do these smell like
flowers
what do you think it's gonna [ __ ]
smell like oh my god huh tell me
that's why
hellotushy.com is here to save the day
but days are back [ __ ] okay
there's no need to walk around with
stinky balls or stinky pistain or that
[ __ ] crease between your legs and
your and your nut sack that smells like
a goat's [ __ ] neck you don't need
that no more go to hellotushy.com
the days are back beautiful
break it down for them leave because i'm
too high to break it down oh they're
amazing they saved my life
i should start every day with one you
you get on you have hot or cold the i
have the cold it took me less than 30
minutes to install it's great you put it
right on and i can't do anything at the
house and it's it's amazing it just gets
you clean i don't do for real you know
yeah joey does the whole the turtleneck
the difference i don't do that i just do
the adjusting
i perfected this little rock and roll
method that gets the front of the bag
shut up oh and you know what hello
pushy.com right now you got a 60 day
money back guarantee tell them lee don't
sit there like a [ __ ] monster do it
just do it now you know
you don't you don't know what you've
been missing you don't know what you've
been missing
they're unbelievable you snap them right
on they're easy to install hot water
cold water let me tell you something you
don't know what life is to waters clean
your muffler oh you're avoiding bacteria
i really do
diseases germs you got to wash that
aspirin four times a day because it's
unbelievable even when you don't take a
poop you should be washing that muffin
yeah you're eating all those gmos and
all those potato chips what do you think
happens in your [ __ ] what do you
think happens to lee's [ __ ] with all
that humble but that's not can we not
think of that creeps around the ring
like sheetrock around the [ __ ] oh my
god like i saw you you ever get a light
socket and put sheet rock around it
that's what hummus does to this
[ __ ] oh that's why you got to get
hellopushy.com right now and if you go
to hellotushy.com right now and press in
church boom c-h-u-r-c-h you get 10 off
to all my listeners remember 60 day
money back guarantee let me tell you
something it's a great product and it's
a great product for valentine's day
let's say you date somebody and they
have a smelly ass so you try to toss
their salad and their [ __ ] thinks
like jersey you can't tell them listen i
can't toss your salad no more because
you ask all those things but if you get
them hello tushie.com it's a very subtle
way that's a great idea yeah i have sex
you go go in there and get the hello
tushy on you i gave you so for
valentine's day it's the best product
it's durable it's solid i love them as a
company go to hellotushy.com right now
and press in church and if you if you
live in a place that has more than one
bathroom do yourself a favor and just
get two of them right away because
because then you're gonna be fighting
over it
wow if something happens get a third one
don't live like i did without the sleep
apnea machine i love you [ __ ]
again me kate and ali moose at the tempe
improv thursday friday two shows
saturday two shows come on by and say
hello i appreciate you with all my heart
we'll be back wednesday night again
indochino tushy and honey.com thank you
for sponsoring the show kate i love you
at all my heart thank you for having me
bigger balls and have these [ __ ] in
hollywood oh me you're my daughter and
you [ __ ] bad ass jew love everybody
stay black
hit it
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you